GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CALL. ON
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES TO
ORDER WELCOME TO BACK TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE- WHERE WE
TRADITIONALLY MET BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC- SO I'M GONNA MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN OUR PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE. OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH IT AGAIN
FOR THOSE THAT MIGHT BE TUNING
IN FOR THE FIRST TIME. SO I'M
GOING TO COVER SOME TECHNICAL-
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SAID AND
IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS THE NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BOB
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING ROOM.
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE ALSO USING A
TELECONFERENCE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY AS WELL. FOR THOSE WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE
IS A PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IT'S
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF
ME. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. ONE
ONE FOUR ONE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL
OPEN YOUR MIND AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. AND
THAT'S SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
HEAR YOU AND WE HEAR FROM YOU SO
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER.
I'M GONNA ASK ALL SPEAKERS
INCLUDING MY COLLEAGUES- AND
WITNESSES- LIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE WILL ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. AND A REMINDER TO
MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE IS FOR THE ROLL
CALL AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE-
MEMBER OF SENATOR GROVE IS ALSO
AT A HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING
WHICH IS ACROSS THE STREET IN
THE- STREET. SWING SPACE
BUILDING. SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
YOU KNOW OUR SHE WILL JOIN US AT
SOME POINT BUT SHE IS DOING
DOUBLE DUTY DUTY TODAY WITH A
LITTLE MORE DISTANCE IN BETWEEN
THOSE HEARING ROOMS. SO I HAVE A
LOT OF SYMPATHY FOR CENTER GROVE
TODAY. AND WITH THAT SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YOUR HERE. HERE HERE. OKAY I'M
GOING TO- LOOK TO TAKE UP SOME
ITEMS IN ADVANCE OF OUR
APPOINTEES ARE BEING. A COMING
FORWARD FIRST AND I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE IT I JUST GO AHEAD DO
THIS IF I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM TWO WHICH IS BILL
REFERRALS AND I THINK WE CAN
TAKE ITEM NUMBER FLOW FOR WHICH
IS A FLOOR A KNOWLEDGE MINTS.
TOGETHER IS ONE ITEM. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS SENATOR LAYERED MAKES
THE MOTION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LOGGER I.
LAYERED ARE AIRED I BATES. BILL
REFERRAL SIMPLER KNOWLEDGE MINT
. BATES AYE ATKINS HI SINCE I'VE
THANK YOU WE ARE UNTIL IT'S ON
CALL BECAUSE SENATOR GROWTH WILL
JOIN US LATER SO THAT WAS ITEM
TO BILL REFERRALS ALONG WITH
ITEM FOR FLOORING KNOWLEDGE
MINTS ON CALL WE ARE ALL GOING
TO GET USED TO BE IN BACK IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- AND WITH THAT I
WILL ASK IF THERE IS A- MOTION
TO TAKE UP ITEM- TO. A MOTION ON
ITEM THREE OF RULE WAIVER
REQUEST WHICH IS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON TO INVOKE ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHT B. OF THE
CONSTITUTION TO DISPENSE WITH
THE THREE READINGS ON THREE DAYS
REQUIREMENT FOR AB. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE GRACE SO MOVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED- MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER I LAYERED LAYERED I BATES
. BATES NO ATKINS HI A CONCISE
ON CALL THAT IS ON CALL AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND WE WILL START WITH ITEM ONE
A. AND THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT
OF SUSAN A TO MORRIS AS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING. AND
SO LET ME SAY WELCOME TO YOU AND
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE GOT UNDER WAY I'M
GOING TO INVITE YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND TO OBVIOUSLY A
KNOWLEDGE OR THANK YOU THE ONE
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS. OF PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
DO THAT AND AFTER YOU'VE
CONCLUDED YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO SENATORS FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND WITH
THAT LET ME AGAIN SAY WELCOME.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUSAN TO
MORRIS AND I'M HONORED TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR CONFIRMATION AS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. TODAY I'M
PROUDTO BE DON'T BE JOINED
VIRTUALLY BY MY TWO DAUGHTERS
SARAH IN SACRAMENTO AND ERIN IN
SAN FRANCISCO. IN ADDITION TO MY
THREE SISTERS JANET IN REDDING
SHANNON MOUNT SHASTA AND SERRA
IN SAN DIEGO. DURING OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY I HOPE TO
DEMONSTRATE MY PASSION FOR THIS
WORK. STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
AGING AND DISABILITY NETWORK IS
MUCH MORE THAN A JOB FOR ME. MY
SISTERS AND I SHARED CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR MOM. WHO
LIVED INDEPENDENTLY WITH
DEMENTIA AND RURAL LAKE COUNTY
BEFORE SHE SUFFERED A
DEBILITATING STROKE THAT
NECESSITATED YEARS A MEDIC CAL
FUNDED NURSING HOME CARE. I
FIRST HAND CARE GIVING
EXPERIENCE WHILE WORKING FULL
TIME AND RAISING TEENAGE
DAUGHTERS. INFLUENCES MY
THINKING AS A STAFF LEADER. AS A
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AND AS THE LEAD
INTO T. FOR THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING. I'M INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
APPOINTING ME TO THIS ROLE AND
I'M EAGER TO ALIGN MY
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THE
FIVE OLD GOALS AND CALIFORNIA'S
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. NUMBER
ONE HOUSING FOR ALL AGES AND
STAGES. TO HELP REIMAGINE. THREE
INCLUSION AND EQUITY NOT
ISOLATION FOR CARE GIVING THAT
WORKS AND FIVE AFFORDING AGING.
I'LL TALK ABOUT IT DURING OUR
TIME TODAY BUT THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING IS CALIFORNIA'S NORTH
NORTH STAR AND THE STATE'S TEN
YEAR BLUEPRINT TO PREPARE FOR
THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY ONE ONE
AND FOR CALIFORNIANS WILL BE AGE
SIXTY OR OLDER. MY THREE DECADES
OF WORK IN SACRAMENTO AS THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR LOBBYIST.
CONSUMER ADVOCATE AND HEALTH
POLICY EXPERT HAS PREPARED ME
FOR TODAY'S CONFIRMATION
HEARING. TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO I
STARTED MY CAREER WITH LEADING
H. CALIFORNIA AS THEIR STAFF
LOBBYIST FOCUSED ON AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING. ASSISTED LIVING
AND NONPROFIT SKILLED NURSING
PROVIDERS. FROM THEIR ISLAND UC
DAVIS HEALTH SYSTEMS GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS PROGRAM
FOR SEVEN YEARS. IN THIS ROLE I
GAINED EXPERTISE ON MEDICARE
MEDICAID AND VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION FINANCING AS WELL
AS MEDICAL AND NURSING EDUCATION
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS I SERVED AS
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE NATIONAL ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WHERE I GAVE VOICE
TO CALIFORNIANS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA. THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IT WAS IN THIS ROLE THAT I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS AN
APPOINTED MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER AS WELL AS A MEMBER
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ALZHEIMER'S
PREVENTION AND PREPAREDNESS TASK
FORCE. IT IS SUCH A HIGH HONOR
TO USE MY PERSONAL. AND
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND
I WELCOME QUESTIONS. FROM ALL OF
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS AND I THINK I'M
GONNA MEDEVACED HERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START UPS STARTERS
OFFICES YOUR WHEEL HOUSE I THINK
. WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT VERY
COMPREHENSIVE A- PRESENTATION OF
OUR DIRECTOR NORRIS AND ON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT SECTOR OF
OUR SOCIETY- OFTEN OVERLOOKED. I
THINK I AM NOT AS VULNERABLE AS
THEY TRULY ARE SO APPRECIATE
THAT I AM ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HOUSING ISSUE AND WE KNOW
THAT THOSE MOST VULNERABLE DO
INCLUDE OUR SENIORS. ARE WITH
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND ALL THAT
THAT BROUGHT FORWARD IS
CERTAINLY THAT THE GREAT
RECESSION SO. AND WONDERING HOW
THE DEPARTMENT IS COLLABORATING
CERTAINLY OUT OF STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ISSUE FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
COULD YOU. GIVE US SOME IDEA OF
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE THERE
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO YOUR
LEGISLATORS AS WE CONTINUE TO-
CONFRONT THE HOUSING ISSUE IN
OUR STATE YEAH AND THE LACK
THERE OF. OF IT FOR CERTAINLY
ALL OUR YOUNGER PEOPLE- WHO WILL
BE GROWING INTO INDEPENDENCE AND
DOWN OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
WHICH ARE. SENIORS ARE CERTAINLY
CLASSIFIED. THANK YOU SEE BATES
FOR THAT. AND YOU YOU LIKELY
KNOW THAT- ADULTS FIFTY AND
OLDER ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
DEMOGRAPHIC IN OUR STATE AMONG
THE HOMELESSNESS POPULATION- NOT A SURPRISE THAT THE
NUMBER ONE GOAL IN THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING. IS HOUSING FOR
ALL AGES AND STAGES. AND THE
STRENGTH OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING IS THE COMPREHENSIVE VIEW
THAT IT TAKES WORKING ACROSS
AGENCIES- THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY HOUSING AGENCY.
TO ADDRESS- B. THE NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS I'M FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HOUSING WITH SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. AND TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR
STATE. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WE WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENTS AND EIGHT AND
AGENCIES- ON HOUSING ISSUES WE
WORK MOST CLOSELY WITH OUR AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING. AND ARE AGING
AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY SERVE AS A KEY REFERRAL
POINTS- TO LINK OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. HOUSING
OPTIONS- IN MY ROLE AS DIRECTOR
I'VE ALSO BEEN NAMED TO THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS AND I HAVE-
ATTENDED ONE MEETING THUS FAR
BUT I'M VERY IMPRESSED. BY THE
DIVERSE CROSS SECTION OF EXPERTS
AND ADVOCATES WHO SERVE IN THAT.
ON THAT- COUNCIL ALONG WITH THE
TWO TWO. CABINET SECRETARIES WHO
LEAD BACK FROM. HOUSING AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. THANK
YOU FOR THAT OUT I JUST STARTED
FIVE JUST TO BE TO YOUR- IF I'M
SURE YOU. COULD BE VERY AWARE OF
IT. VERY VERY AWARE OF THAT THAT
THE RENOWNED. A REQUIREMENTS
REALLY MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO SOME
COMMUNITIES TO. ADDRESS THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF THE
AFFORDABILITY AND IN PARTICULAR
TO FOCUS ON PARTICULAR GROUPS.
THERE ARE SO MANY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. COMMITTEES ON AGING
AND SENIOR CENTERS I'M JUST
SAYING THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT THAT THEY GET DIALED
AND IF. IF THE OUTRAGE CAN BE
EXPANDED TO TALK. THROUGH THOSE
OUR COMMUNITY AGENCIES ABOUT THE
NEED SPECIFICALLY FOR HIM THOSE
COMMUNITIES ON. THE APPROACH TO
ALLOWING CERTAIN LEVEL HOUSING
THAT WILL ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED WITH.
HOW THE COMMUNITIES CERTAINLY IN
MY DISTRICT ARE STARTING TO COME
TOGETHER THE CITY. TO ADDRESS
MORE AND REGIONAL MANNER WHAT
WHAT THEIR DEMOGRAPHICS ARE IN
AND IN PARTICULAR AS- WE LOOK AT
THE AGE COMPONENT OF THAT. IN
REALLY- KIND OF DOUBLE DOWN ON
TRYING TO FIND. OR THEY CAN
CREATE THE HOUSING THAT ADDRESS
US ISSUE THAT ARE NOT JUSTICE TO
LIVE WE HAVE. A NUMBER OF THOSE
BUT FUN ARE WHO WANT TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENT INDIVIDUAL.
APARTMENTS LIVING ON THEIR OWN I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF CONTINUING TO BE
POSITIVE. AS WE AGE- AND CONNECT
WITH OUR COMMUNITY SO JUST TO
KIND OF PUT THAT INTO THE HOPPER
OFFER. A DISCUSSION AS YOU GO
FORWARD ONE LAST QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY ARE WITH THE PANDEMIC
OF THE- PARTICULAR AGE GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY
AFFECTED BY THE ISOLATION HAS
BEEN. THE TWO ENDS OF THE
SPECTRUM ARE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THOSE SENIORS- BECAUSE A LACK OF
ABILITY TO SOCIALIZE WHICH IS SO
VERY IMPORTANT TO GOOD. YOU KNOW
MENTAL HEALTH. SO I KNOW YOU HAD
THE F. FINDER REMEMBERING IT
CORRECTLY A FRIENDSHIP. OF LINE
FOR CRISIS AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
pGIVE A LITTLE- UPDATE ON HOW
THAT'S WORKED ARE THERE ANY BEST
PRACTICES COMING OUT OF THAT-
THAT WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IN IN
TERMS OF OUR REFERRALS. OF
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU RAY- WE
SHARE CAN ABOUT ISOLATE THAT IS
A GOAL IN THE MASTER PLAN FOR
ASIAN FOR THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING. INCLUSION AND EQUITY NOT
ISOLATION AND THAT CAME OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC SO YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS SO
CROWDED THAT THE FRIENDSHIP LINE
WAS. WAS OFFERED- FREE OF CHARGE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE A- A WARM CONVERSATION
WITH A LIVE HUMAN AND TO DATE
WE'VE RECEIVED OVER A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND. CALLS
THROUGH THE FRIENDSHIP LINE AND
THAT CONTINUES TODAY- IN
ADDITION WE HAVE MADE DIRECT
CONTACT TO. ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE THREE POINT SIX MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS. WHERE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SHARE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AVAILABLE TO THEM
STATEWIDE REGIONALLY AND LOCALLY
SO THAT THEY CAN. CONNECT OR-
SENIOR NUTRITION- ALZHEIMER'S
SUPPORTS- ABUSE AND NEGLECT SO
WE HAVE PROVIDED- POSTCARDS TO
HOUSEHOLDS- OF OLDER ADULTS AND
WE PROVIDED THOSE IN LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH. AND WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED THAT- AS WE
SPEAK- WE ARE OPENING UP AGAIN
OUR ADULT DAY EALTHCARE CENTERS
AROUND THE STATE. AND SENIOR
CONGREGATE SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS ARE RETURNING TO IN
PERSON- ACTIVITIES AND THAT'S
ALL MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE
HIGH RATE OF VACCINATIONS. AMONG
THE- THE SIXTY FIVE PLUS WE'RE
AT AN EIGHTY THREE PERCENT. TAX
AND THAT ALLOWS OLDER ADULTS AND
SAFELY COME AGAIN IN THE CA
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT. TO COMBAT
ISOLATION. THANK YOU THERE ARE
SEVERAL REALLY GOOD NEWS FOR ALL
OF US BUT ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR RESPONSES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR DEDICATION IN THIS
SPACE IT'S BEEN FULL VERY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE- THE
DEPARTMENT ON AGING AND FOCUSING
ON THEIR- END OF THE CONTINUUM
SO. YOU'VE BEEN OUT THE
HEADWATERS OF THE R. ANDO
CERTAINLY I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT
AND YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR OF THE CENTER COM MARKER.
MADAM PRO TEM AND- THANK YOU
FOR. GOING UP TODAY I IT WAS I
THINK WE HAD A VERY NICE
CONVERSATION ON MONDAY- OR
TUESDAY AND SO IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU HERE- I REALLY JUST HAVE-
TWO QUESTIONS- ONE IS I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SAW THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE IN TODAY'S LA TIMES.
REGARDING HOSPICE AND HOSPICE
CARE AND WHILE I KNOW IT'S NOT
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING I
THINK HOSPICE IS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH- AB
IT IS STILL AN ISSUE THAT
IMPACTS OUR AGING POPULATION AND
SO THE ARTICLE IN THE ISSUES
THAT SORT OF RESULTED FROM AN
AUDIT. CONDUCTED BY THE STATE
YOU KNOW SPEAK TO THE FRAMEWORK
. BY WHICH CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS
OUR SENIORS- AND CARES FOR THE
AGING. AND THE VULNERABILITIES
OF OUR SYSTEM YOU KNOW- SORT OF
IRONICALLY DESIGNED YOU KNOW FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE SO JUST
WANTED TO KNOW- AID TO CDA
COLLABORATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THEN BE
WHAT ROLE KID OF DO YOU SEE-
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING PLAYING
IN HOW WE TACKLE THIS ISSUE
AROUND PROVIDING- QUALITY
HOSPICE CARE. THANK YOU SENATOR
COME UNDER THREAT FOR MEETING
WITH ME- AND ALSO FOR THAT
QUESTION AND YES I'M NOT I'M
AWARE OF THAT REPORT THAT WAS
ISSUED JUST YESTERDAY. AND YOUARE CORRECT THAT- HOSPICE
AGENCIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OVERSEEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT
IN OUR ROLE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AND AS THE LEAD ENTITY FOR
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING WE
LOOK AT THE FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE- THAT'S PROVIDED TO OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AT ALL STAGES OF
THEIR LIFESPAN. AND HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ARE CERTAINLY
CRITICAL PIECES OF THAT
CONTINUUM OF CARE- IN TERMS OF
OUR ROLE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING- WE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED
TO. PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES LOCALLY SO THAT THEY
CAN MAKE WELL INFORMED CHOICES
ABOUT THEIR OPTIONS FOR CARE AT
EVERY LEVEL INCLUDING HOSPICE
AND PALLIATIVE CARE- AND WE'RE
VERY COMMITTED AND GRATEFUL TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR SUPPORT. TO SUPPORT A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN BETTER NAVIGATE
ALL OF THE OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM THROUGH A
VARIETY OF FUNDING SOURCES
INCLUDING MEDICARE. MEDICAID
I'LL VETERANS BENEFITS AND THAT
WOULD INCLUDE HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE SO OUR ROLE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS
REALLY TO EQUIP PEOPLE WITH THE
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED. TO MAKE THE RIGH
CHOICE FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE DO COLLABORATE.
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. CARE SERVICES AS A MEDIC
CAL. PROVIDER IN OUR STATE AND I
AT THE MANSION THIS IS NEW
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM AND IN. THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME ON THIS
TOPIC. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT. YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALKED- I
THINK I TOLD YOU THAT I THOUGHT
ONE OF THE MOST OVERLOOKED
POPULATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OUR SENIORS AND
YET SO MANY OF US HAVE. STORIES
THAT WE CAN SHARE ABOUT PEOPLE
IN OUR LIVES WHO ARE- OUR
ELDERS. THAT WE LOVE- AND THAT
WE YOU KNOW WE LOVE THEM THROUGH
EACH STAGE OF THEIR LIFE. IN
THIS CHALLENGES THAT WERE FACED
AS THEY GOT OLDER IN NEEDED CARE
AND SO WE TALKED ABOUT- TWO
THINGS. NURSING CARE FACILITIES
AND THEN KICK CARE GIVERS HOW WE
SUPPORT AND HOW WE SEE OUR CARE
GIVERS. AND I KNOW THAT CTA'S
RECENTLY CREATED THE OFFICE OF
LONG TERM CARE PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE- WHICH I THINK IS
SUPPOSED TO HELP FOCUS WITH OUR
NURSING CARE ISSUES- AND I KNOW
THAT YOU- CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
ROLE OF THE- PAID FAMILY CARE
GIVER. SO JUST WANTED TO GET
SORT OF YOUR THOUGHTS BECAUSE WE
DO KNOW THAT ON AVERAGE. THE
CARE GIVERS IN THE SPACE ARE YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY THEIR FORTY SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT YEARS OLD THEY TEND
TO BE WOMEN THEY TEND TO BE
WOMEN OF COLOR. SO CAN YOU TALK
TO- WHAT CALIFORNIA PLANS TO DO
TO HELP THIS POPULATION YOU KNOW
OUR UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS AS
WELL AS SUPPORTING. OUR CARE
GIVER STRUCTURE ARE PAID FAMILY
CARE GIVER STRUCTURE YOU KNOW
THESE FOLKS ARE WORKING REALLY
HARD. BURN OUT. UNDER RESOURCE.
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY NECESSARILY
HAVE SUPPORTS ARE OFTEN
STRUGGLING THROUGH- THIS- WORK
ALONE- WITHOUT ALWAYS ANSWERS TO
QUESTIONS THAT ARE IMPACTING
THEIR LOVED ONES OFTEN TIMES
THEIR PARENTS OR THEIR
GRANDPARENTS- AND THEN ALSO SORT
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND THE
NURSING CARE SPACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE ARE FACILITIES THAT-
YOU KNOW HAVE THE CAPACITY- HAVE
A STRUCTURE IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. AND SAFETY
AND THE CARE- I THINK OF OUR
MOST PRECIOUS POPULATION- WOULD
LOVE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THANK YOU SO THAT IT THAT IS A
TWO PART QUESTION I'LL TAKE THE-
WORKS THE CARE GIVER AND
WORKFORCE QUESTION FIRST- SO WE
DO HAVE FOUR MILLION FAMILY
CAREGIVERS AND OUR STATE. AND
THOSE ARE UNPAID ROLES AND THEY
ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR STATE'S
LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM PROVIDING
FAR AND AWAY MORE CARE IN HOMES-
THAT ARE PAID WORKFORCE AND
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC. EARLY WOMEN WOMEN
OF COLOR- WHO ARE CARING FOR
LOVED ONES IN THEIR HOME- SO THE
WAY THAT THE STATE HAS APPROACH
THAT AND WE'RE INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR- THE ANCHOR- FOR
OUR STATES- CARE GIVERS. SYSTEM
WOULD BE THE ELEVEN CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS WE HAVE A
NETWORK THAT IS STATEWIDE AND
AVAILABLE- IN EVERY COMMUNITY
FREE OF CHARGE TO SUPPORT THE
CARE GIVER- IN ADDITION- THERE
WAS SPENDING IN THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SPENDING PLAN
THAT WENT- TO FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
ALZHEIMER'S PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS PLAN I WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
TO SUPPORT FAMILY CAREGIVERS
WITH. TRAINING IN ADDITION- CAL
AIMAR MEDIKAL INITIATIVE- NOW
INCLUDES RESPITE SUPPORTS AS A
MEDIC CAL BENEFIT AND THAT WILL
BE HUGE FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
WHO HAVE A LOVED ONE WHO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE NOW. AND
THEN LAST BUT NOT LEAST- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE
OLDER AMERICANS ACT. PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
CAREGIVER SUPPORTS AND TRAINING
AND ALL OF THOSE DOLLARS FLOW
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
AND GO DIRECTLY TO OUR AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND THEY BASED
THIS FIRST THOSE DOLLARS
LOCALLY- THROUGH. THROUGH.
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS. IN TERMS
OF THE PAID WORKFORCE- AGAIN THE
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES RELY ON THE FULL
CONTINUUM OF. WORKERS AND- WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR I'M FOR
APPROVING NEARLY A BILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR IN DIRECT CARE
WORKFORCE FINDING THAT TODAY IS
BEING SPENT ON IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING WE
ARE WORKING WITH HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS LIKE
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE. PROGRAM
FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY AND THE MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM WHERE
WE'RE PROVIDING TRAINING AND
STIPENDS FOR THE DIRECT CARE
WORKFORCE. AND IN ADDITION
CERTIFIED NURSE AIDES WHO
PROVIDE THE BULK OF WORK IN
NURSING HOMES- THERE'S FUNDING
THAT SUPPORTS- CAREER PATHWAYS
PIPELINES AND INCENTIVES FOR
CERTIFIED PAINS AND THAT IS
BEING- OVERSEEN BY. H. CHI. SO
THOSE WOULD BE THAT THE INFORMAL
AND FORMAL CARE GIVER AND ISSUED
ITS AND THEN WE'RE VERY EXCITED
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN FURTHER
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. IS WOULD
GO TOWARDS SOCIAL WORKERS NURSES
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS.
THE SECOND PIECE OF YOUR
QUESTION RELATED TO NURSING
FACILITIES AND IN OUR STATE WE
HAVE TWELVE HUNDRED LICENSED
NURSING HOMES. THEY ARE-
OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MANY OF THEM RECEIVE MEDICAID
FUNDING- SO THERE'S A LINK TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. OUR ROLE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS LIMITED
TO THE STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN BONTA CASTRO WHO WAS
APPOINTED. INTO HER ROLE ON THIS
ANYWHERE IS DOING AT. JOB
WORKING WITH A- THE THIRTY FIVE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHERE WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY
EIGHT CERT VOLUNTEERS AND ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY STAFF MEMBERS.
WHO REPRESENT THE NEEDS AND
INTERESTS AND PREFERENCES AND
RIGHTS OF NURSING HOM RESIDENTS
THAT THEIR CLIENT IS THE NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS. AND OUR
OMBUDSMAN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE BEEN DOING A FANTASTIC JOB
RE ENTERING NURSING FACILITIES
TO SUPPORT- THE RESIDENTS THERE.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED WE DID JUST
ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE. BEIJING
AND SUSAN RODRIGUEZ HAS BEEN A-
NAME TO THAT TO LEAVE THAT
OFFICE AND THEY ARE THE FOCUS IS
ON INDIVIDUALS WHO RESIDE IN
NURSING HOMES WHO HAVE NO
FAMILY. NO FRIENDS THEIR
UNSUPPORTED AND REPRESENTED AND
THE ASSIST- THOSE RESIDENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR HEALTHCARE
WISHES AND THEIR RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
INFORMATIVE RESPONSE AND- THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR THE TIME THAT
YOU GAVE ME EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND LOOK FORWARD TO- SUPPORTING
YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. HE CENTER.
THANK YOU US SENATOR LAYERED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR INTO A- TO
THE DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR THE
MEETING EARLIER IN THE WEEK-
I'M- THURMOND GREAT QUESTIONS
AND IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO
FOLLOW. UP TO MEMBERS THAT HAVE
HAVE RULING. FOR SOME OF THE
ISSUES SO LET ME GO TO THE TOP
LEVEL OF WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
WHICH IS. A TEN YEAR MASTER PLAN
WAS ADOPTED FOR SERVICES WERE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS SHOOTING
FOR TWENTY THIRTY- AND IT'S A
BLUEPRINT. M. THE ONE THING THE
LEGISLATURE DID LAST YEAR IS WE
GAVE YOU MANY POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE- THE PLAN. WHAT
SHOULD WE EXPECT TO SEE THAT'S
PRACTICAL THAT'S COMING OUT OF
THE PLAN IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WHERE DO YOU THINK. THERE ARE
GAPS OR- FOR ADDITIONAL SERVICES
THAT ARE PART OF THAT PLAN THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO REALLY
FOCUS ON AND YOU MAY WELL BE
COMING BACK TO US FOR. FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED AND THANK YOU
ALSO FOR TAKING THE TIME TO MEET
WITH ME IN PERSON- TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION I WOULD SAY IT IT
IT IS TWO FOLD- WHEN. WE
CELEBRATED THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR'S MESSAGE AND SECRETARY
MARK GALLEYS MESSAGE WAS. WE'RE
JUST GETTING STARTED SO TO YOUR
POINT- I'D SAY IN THE MOST FRONT
AND CENTER ISSUE TODAY IS THE
WORK FORCE CRISIS. AND WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING.ACROSS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AS WELL AS WITH
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY HONEST WHEAT
AS- INVESTMENTS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER DIRECT WORK. IN SUPPORT
SERVICES FRONTLINE WORKERS-
CERTIFIED NURSE AIDES- LICENSE
BILL. NURSES. OUR WAY AND WE'LL
- IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS. TO
SUPPORT IN AND THEIR- IN
COMMUNITIES AND THEN MY SETTINGS
AS THE SYSTEM LIVING AND NURSING
HOMES AND WE ALSO OLDER ADULTS
AND- ARE HIGHER UTILIZE THERE'S
A HOSPITAL SERVICES THAT WE NEED
THE WORK FORCE AND ALL OF THOSE
SETTINGS. ESPECIALLY ALL
SERVICES- SO THAT'S THAT IS AND
CENTER RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL CONTINUE THOSE INVESTMENTS-
IN THIS YEAR'S IN THE PROPOSED.
AND WE'LL SEE. MORE WORK WITH
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS SOCIAL
WORKERS AND NURSES IN THE
ENSUING IN SEVEN YEARS. OUR OUR
DEPARTMENT US SPECIFICALLY I
WOULD SAY- OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS WILL BE LASER FOCUSED ON
THE NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM THAT I
MENTIONED. AND THAT'S WHERE-
IT'S PART OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AND IT'S REALLY PERSON
CENTERED- CONSUMER FOCUSED. TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WHEREVER THEY ARE WHEREVER THEY
LIVE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS INFORMATION. I FOUND.
THEY GET FIVE. IN MY- ACCESS IN
- US STATE WEB PORTAL THAT IS
INTERACTIVE- AND- OF COURSE
ACCESS INFORMATION. LOCALLY IN
PERSON THEIR AREA AGENCY ON
AGING OR THEIR AGING AND JUST
RESOURCE CAN. EIGHTY C. RIGHT
NOW I'M ARE ARE X. HAS- WE'RE
VERY PROUD WE NOW THIRTY
COUNTIES IN OUR STATE. THAT
MEANS TWENTY EIGHT ARE NOT YET
COVERED SO THAT WILL BE OUR
FOCUS IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS AS
WE TRY TO TAKE THAT STATEWIDE.
LET ME FOLLOW UP BECAUSE IT IT
SEEMS THAT AND YOU SAID IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT THAT THERE
WERE. I'M I'M NOT RECALLING THE
NUMBER EXACTLY THREE OR FOUR
MILLION REFERRALS OR- OR A
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION THAT
FORMAT. BUT THENAS A REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION THAT SERVICES
THAT AREN'T FULLY DEVELOPED FOR.
ARE ADEQUATE RIGHT NOW SO IF. D.
A. THE EIGHT YOU JUST COMMENTED
THAT IT IS REALLY WORKFORCE
EXPANDING THE WORK FORCE AND
CARE BECAUSE THE BOOM. IN ELDERS
IS COMING AND SO IS IT REALLY.
ALL THE EXISTING KINDS OF
SERVICES ARE THERE IT'S THE
VOLUME THAT ISN'T THERE AND ITS
WORK FORCE THAT IS THE REAL
ISSUE ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S AN ADEQUATE VOLUME OF
CARE SERVICES AVAILABLE. AN
INTERNET I BELIEVE IT IT IS
BOTH- IN IN TERMS OF-
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDING OUT OUR
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY TO PREPARE FOR TWENTY
THIRTY WHEN WE KNOW THE VOLUME
WILL BE. AT A LEVEL WE'VE NEVER
EVER SEEN IN OUR STATE BEFORE.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT IS AN
AREA THAT WILL BE TALKING TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT IS HOW WE
BUILD- A CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIP
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- A
STANDARDIZED INTAKE AND
ASSESSMENT PROCESS THAT- WHAT
WHICHEVER COUNTY AREA AND- WE
CAPTURE IMPORTANT DATA INCLUDING
SO G. DATA- DATE ON AIDS-
ETHNICITY AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN BE A TRULY DATA
DRIVEN- SYSTEM IN OUR STATE.
ALSO TO BUILD THAT- WE DO OFFER
AN EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER
STATEWIDE TODAY BUT TO BE ABLE.
AND TO REFER PEOPLE TO THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AND TO HAVE
. CULTURALLY COMPETENT SERVICES
AVAILABLE IN THE LANGUAGE OF AS
CHOICE WILL TAKE SOME CAPACITY
BUILDING AND THEN TO YOUR HERE
POINT- ABOUT THE WORK FORCE. IF
YOU HAVE A CENTRALIZED
NAVIGATION SYSTEM AND A REFERRAL
PROCESS THAT THAT THE NETWORK IS
INADEQUATE AND WE DON'T HAVE
SUFFICIENT- PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO MEET PEOPLE'S NEEDS
OR WE DON'T HAVE THE WORKFORCE
AVAILABLE STAFF THOSE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES- WE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING. AND WORKFORCE
OVERLAYS BOTH OF THOSE. WE'RE
USING TOGETHER MY CONCERN BUT
I'M STILL NERVOUS BECAUSE IT IT
SEEMS THAT. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
BE REALLY GOOD IN THE REFERRAL
SYSTEM AND REALLY GOOD AT THE
INFORMATIONAL SYSTEM AND WE'RE
REALLY ON SURE THAT THEY'LL BE
AN ADEQUATE LEVEL OF SERVICES
THERE- TO REFORM TO. AN
OBVIOUSLY THE WORK FORCE IS A
MAJOR ISSUE DO YOU THINK IF WE
WERE TO DEVELOP SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL WORK FORCE. THAT WILL
GET US THERE OR DO YOU THINK
THAT THERE ARE SUCH A LEVEL OF
FACILITY SERVICES AND OTHER
THINGS THAT THE WORK FORCE IS
THE FIRST STEP. AND OTHER STEPS
BECAUSE- THIS IS HAPPENING. A.
N. ARE WE HAVE FIND OUT WERE IN
IT. AND WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
MARCHING DOWN THE PATH A
DIFFERENT WAY ON THE WAY TO
BEING IN SO HOW DO YOU. HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT'S NOT
JUST WORK FORCE BUT HAVING THE
BROADER AVAILABILITY OF THESE
KINDS OF SERVICE. WHAT THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING WAS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP TO OUTLINE-
OUR NETWORK OUR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND TO IDENTIFY GAPS AND
MOST CERTAINLY THROUGH THE KOBE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE. DISCOVERED
WHERE IN OUR STATE WERE LACKING
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR
INDIVIDUAL WHETHER THEIR ACUTE
CARE. LONG TERM CARE OR HOME
CARE- SO WE HAVE LEARNED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS ABOUT INADEQUACIES IN
OUR SYSTEM. IT'S NOT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING BUT- THE
LEGISLATURE- DID SUPPORT- AT
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES- ROAD MAP THAT WILL BE-
EMBARKED UPON BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT WE
ARE IN A- IN A ACTIVELY MOVING
TOWARDS- S. WHERE WE WILL MAP
ALL OF THE SYSTEMS AND SERVICES.
ACROSS OUR STATE NOT ONLY
MEDICAL SERVICES BUT MANY
SERVICES SUCH AS THE ONES
PROVIDED BY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING THAT DON'T HAVE. AN INCOME
THRESHOLD THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANYONE IN THE COMMUNITY BASED ON
NEED SO WE ARE- IN THE PROCESS
NOW OF MAPPING ALL OF THESE
SERVICES SO THAT WE CAN. TELL
COUNTY BY COUNTY WHAT IS
AVAILABLE AND WHAT IS NOT
AVAILABLE AND THEN TO BUILD OUT.
A STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF. SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND- I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
YOU AND YOU INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF SLOTS IN OUR MSSP WHICH IS
THE MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM- YOU HAVE
CONTINUED TO SUPPORT- SEE BASS
THE COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICES. PROGRAM THAT'S ADULT
DAY HEALTH CARE- SO WE'VE SEEN
INVESTMENTS TO INCREASE CAPACITY
D. AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO. YOU KNOW CONTINUE WITH THOSE
INVESTMENTS. I THINK THAT THAT'S
MY POINT IS. IS THERE A ROAD MAP
TO THE CONTINUE INVESTMENTS
THAT'S COMING FROM THIS PLAN.
FOR IT ARE WE JUST IDENTIFYING
WHERE THERE'S GAPS IN STORE-
LEGALLY MOVING TOWARD IT I MEAN
HOW ARE WE REALLY. GOING TO
ADDRESS WHAT THE GAPS ARE IN THE
SYSTEM. WE'RE IN THE BEGINNING
STAGES OF- BUILDING THAT ROAD
MAP THAT WILL IDENTIFY THE GAPS
AND THE NEXT STEP AFTER THAT
WOULD BE TO SELL THOSE CLOSE
THOSE GAPS- ONCE WE KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE AND THE LEVEL OF CARE
WHAT IS NEEDED- SO WE HAVE. A
GOOD DEAL OF ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION AND WE CAN CERTAINLY
TELL YOU. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WHICH COUNTIES HAVE ADULT
DAY HEALTHCARE CENTERS AND WHICH
DO NOT- BUT EVEN IF- WITH A MAP
LIKE THAT- IN A LARGE COUNTY YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE COUNTIES THAT
YOU HAVE. TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE IN YOUR
COUNTY- IT MIGHT BE A THREE HOUR
DRIVE FOR SOMEBODY TO GET ACROSS
THE COUNTY ACCESS THAT SO. WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE THINK THE FIRST STEP
IS NAVIGATION THEN ACCESS.
WHETHER IT'S WORK AND THEN WORK
FORCE AND THEY ALL GO HAND IN
HAND. TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM TO
ACCESS THE SERVICES. THAT ARE
NEEDED AND- LOOKING AT THE
POPULATION YOU KNOW THE
DEMOGRAPHIC INDIVIDUALS FOR
INSTANCE SIXTY TO A HUNDRED ARE
NOT A HOMOGENEOUS GROUP AND THEY
ALL DON'T NEED THE SAME THING AT
THE SAME TIME SO THERE'S SOME
COMPLEXITY TO THIS THAT WILL BE
TALKING TO YOU- IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND YOUR STAFF AND
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW WE
RIGHT SIZED. OUR NETWORK- FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WELL I CAN'T
HELP BUT COMMENT BECAUSE YOU
SAID SIXTY TO A HUNDRED PER
NIGHT OR BOTH IN THAT GROUP AND
WE ARE NOT MUCH OF THIS. IS SO-
BUT THE POINT IS I THINK I'M NOT
GOING TO BEAT THE DEAD HORSE ANY
FURTHER BUT I SPENT ALL THIS
TIME. JERRY MEETINGS HOW DO GET
TO THE END. JUST HOW DO WE GET
TO THE END WE COULD HAVE
PROCESS. FOR A LONG TIME BUT
THEY'LL BE PEOPLE THAT NEED
NURSING HOME SERVICES AND IT
WON'T BE THERE SO. SO JUST KEEP
THAT IN MIND BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
I'M TRYING TO IDENTIFY. THIS HOW
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO MEET
THE NEED HAS SOMEBODY'S GONNA
COME TO US AND SAY HERE'S WITH
THE GAP IS. THAN THAT AND MY
FINAL QUESTION IS RELATED TO
THAT AND- THEN I SORT OF
INTIMATED TO IT WOULDN'T ASK
ANYTHING UNLESS WE- TALKED ABOUT
IT IN THE MEETING BUT THIS IS
DEVELOPED IN A DIFFERENT WAY
STAND. MEMBERS MOVE. TO THE- A
VET. IN THE MONTEREY PENINSULA.
AND IN DRILLING DOWN TO TRY TO
DEAL WITH THIS I'VE HAD ALL
THESE MEETINGS WITH CALVET AND
OF ALL THESE MEETINGS WITH
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS AND
THEY DON'T TALK TO EACH OTHER IN
A CLEAR HUESO I FACILITATED. ARE
AN HOUR LONG MEETING TO GET TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER AND- AND WHAT
WAS DETERMINED. IS THERE'S
ADEQUATE SERVICES AND MEDICAL
DIFFERENT THINGS THERE'S NOT
ADEQUATE SKILLED NURSING AND
THERE'S NOT ADEQUATE MEMORY CARE
FOR VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A WAITING LIST PEOPLE
BEING TURNED AWAY. THEY'RE NOT
ENOUGH SLOTS. THE SO. N. AND
THEN. AND A VERY UNHELPFUL WAY
ONE OF THE ADMINISTRATION PEOPLE
SAID AT THE END OF THE MEETING
ALL THIS IS THE LEGISLATURE'S
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEN THERE
WAS NO ROAD MAP OFFERED. FOR HOW
WE MIGHT MEET THAT NEED WITHIN
VETERANS AND SO. DO YOU WORK
WITH THE VETERANS DEPARTMENT ON
THEIR LONG TERM MORE MEMORY CARE
ISSUES AND ARE THEY PART OF YOUR
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES AND IF
THEY'RE NOT MEETING THEIR NEEDS
DO YOU HAVE THAT INCORPORATED IN
YOUR PLAN AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR WHAT. I WANT TO. THANK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING THE TOPIC OF
VETERANS AND ABS ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S PART OF WHAT I WAS
REFERRING TO AND IN A ROAD MAP
THAT IS NOT LIMITED ONLY TO.
MEDIC CAL GAPS WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT IT'S INCLUSIVE OF
OTHER GAPS INCLUDING WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED- IN THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE VETERANS
DEPARTMENT AND- THE- DEPARTMENT
WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE MASTER
PLANNED DEVELOPMENTS. AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
RELATED TO VETERANS AND THAT- WE
WORK WE DO WORK- IN
COLLABORATION. AND YOU'VE HIT
ON- SORT OF THE SILOS THAT
CONFRONT OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. YEAH THERE
THERE'S FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
MEDICARE AND THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION AND SOCIAL
SECURITY AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS IN
THEIR LOCAL PROGRAMS AND IT. IS
IT CAN BE VERY CONFUSING ON THE
GROUNDS FOR CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES- SO I WILL TAKE THAT
BACK. AND BE SURE TO FOLLOW UP.
ON THAT. TO SEE WHERE THINGS ARE
THE VETERANS HOSPITAL COMING TO
YOUR DISTRICT. YES IT'S I'M NOT
NECESSARILY ADVOCATING FOR THE
HOSPITAL BUT I AM ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR BEING ADEQUATE CARE. FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THOSE
CATEGORIES THAT ARE VETERANS
HOWEVER IT IS AND I KNOW I'VE
TALKED TO ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO THINKS THAT. SB TWO LONG
BILLS. OUT TO PROJECT RIGHT NOW
AND THAT WOULD BE THE THING THAT
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AND SO.
IT'S THE COVERT BUT IT GETS BACK
TO MY CENTRAL CONCERN I'LL JUST
CLOSE WITH THE JUST RESTATED I
REALLY WANT TO KNOW HOW TO GET
TO THE END OF. I WAS THE WAIT
TEN YEARS FOR CONSTRUCTION OF A
HOSPITAL. IN THE ROLE VETERANS
RIGHT NOW WITH WITH THE VOUCHER
COULD FIND MEMORY CARE. WHICH
THEY NEED URGENT. THAT'S
PROBABLY WHAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DO AND I AM WORKING FOR. JUST
ASSISTANCE RATHER THAN. RACIST
HE DOESN'T MATTER THE
LEGISLATORS THE ONE COULD FEEL
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR SYSTEM TO
KNOW THAT YOU ARE WE LOOKING AT
. IF YOU FEEL YOU'RE TALKING.
ABOUT THEY- FEEL IN A CLEAR WAY
THAT HOPING. IS OUT OF THE.
PROCESS A IS NOT MORE PER. BUT
BUT SOME. THAT COULD ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH MIKE.
I PUSH THANK YOU MATT CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR. IS- URGENCY
IS BECAUSE HE HAD A BIRTHDAY
YESTERDAY I THINK OUR- OF THE-
WITH GREAT WITH GREAT
SERIOUSNESS AND RESPECT- IT
MISTER MORRIS I'M REALLY GLAD
YOU'RE HERE AND- HAPPY TO LISTEN
TO THIS CONVERSATION I MADE IT A
NUMBER OF NOTES AND THE GOOD
THING IS MY COLLEAGUES ASK. ALL
THE QUESTIONS ARE TO WHICH I CAN
JUST COMMENT ON- I DO THINK
LISTEN TO YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
AND- YOUR PERSONAL EXPERT.
COMBINE WITH. A PHONE YES BURKE
. AND THEN THE REST YOU'VE GIVEN
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING THUS
FAR. CONVINCES ME THAT YOU WERE
YOU WERE DEEP IN EVERY ASPECT OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AND UNDERSTAND
HOW TO CONNECT THE DOTS AND ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT. YOUR PARTICULAR ROLE BUT
HAVEN'T ALL THESE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THAT TOUCH UPON
VARIOUS ISSUES HOW DO YOU HAVE
THE INFLUENCE HOW YOU HAVE THE
POWER. AND THE ABILITY TO PULL
THESE THINGS TOGETHER AND
WHETHER YOU FEEL THAT'S GOING
WELL THAT WAS THAT'S A KEY
QUESTION I WAS THRILLED TO HEAR
YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
PARTICIPATION EVEN IF YOU'VE
BEEN TO ONE MEETING. IN THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. THIS LEGISLATURE
WORKED VERY HARD TO GET THAT
INTER AGENCY COUNCIL TOOK US
MULTIPLE TRIES TO GET THAT IN
PLACE- I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
ON THE WORK FORCE IT'S ONE OF MY
BIGGEST WORRIES. BECAUSE EVEN AS
WE TALK ABOUT ALLOCATING OR
PROPOSAL OF MORE THAN ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
WORKFORCE ISSUES WE KNOW YOU
MENTIONED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
MEDICAL STAFF GENERALLY- ALL
LEVELS OF NURSING STAFF- MY
BIGGEST CONCERN TO CENTER LAYER
TO POINT IS HOW WE GET FROM
POINT HEY. AND HOW DO THOSE VERY
PRECIOUS DOT. WE HAVE TODAY THAT
NOT ALWAYS HAD HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO GET SPENT. TO GET US TO
THE END AND GET THOSE WORKERS-
WHO ARE ABLE TO FILL IN THE- THE
POSITIONS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES SO. I WILL SAY ALL
ALL OF LINK THE WORK FORCE
ISSUES IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
TOO. AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
CONVERSATION BECAUSE- I CAN
ALREADY SENSE OF PEOPLE- ARE
GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE. I CAN'T
YOU KNOW. OF THIS APPOINTMENT-
WE STILL HAVE THE PUBLIC TO
WEIGH IN. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. YOU KNOW IT
WAS GREAT TO HAVE OUR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN HIS FIRST STATE OF THE
STATE SPEECH. UNVEILED HIS
SUPPORT AND PLAN. FOR THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING. WE HAD A FORMER
SENATOR WHO ALREADY HAD BEEN
WORKING ON THAT IN THE SENATE.
AND HAD A BILL ARE SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON. AND WE HAD
A HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE THAT
I APPOINTED SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE TASK. OF MEMBERS WHO WHO
OVERSAW HEALTH AND HOUSING AND
YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
WITH HER. AS WE PUT THAT PLAN
FORWARD SO IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT HAVE A PLAN. AND A
ROAD MAP. AND IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT HAVE A FRAMEWORK OF
HOW THE INTEGRATION OCCURS IN A
STATE AS LARGE AS CALIFORNIA.
AND A GAP ANALYSIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. BUT I LINK ALL OF
THESE THINGS TOGETHER BECAUSE I
REALLY BELIEVE IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US WE GET TO BE THE ONES TO
CONFIRM APPOINTEES. WE ALSO GET
TO BE THE ONES TO OUR BUDGET
PROCESS TO HAVE A TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COME BACK TO
YOU. NEXT IN THIS YEAR AND NEXT
YEAR AS AS WE GET TO THE
QUESTION THAT THAT CENTER
LAYERED WAS ASKING WHAT WHAT
WILL YOU ONGOING WE NEED FOR US
TO GET THERE AND GET TO THE END.
AND I WANT THAT TO BE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I FULLY
EXPECT THAT WE WILL BE HAVING
ANOTHER CONVERSATION WITH YOU
PROBABLY IN A BUDGET.
PERSPECTIVE OF WHERE ARE WE
BECAUSE I THINK. ON ON EVERY
ISSUE I FEEL LIKE ONCE
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
WE HAVE NOT HAD THE RESOURCES AS
WERE ALL WHERE IN PREVIOUS
YEARS. TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THESE THINGS AND WHEN WE DO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE DOLLARS
ARE SPENT THE WAY THEY NEED TO
BE SPENT TO GET US WHAT WE WANT.
FOR OUR CITIZENS. ARM FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND- YOU KNOW I
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE NO WRONG
DOOR IT'S PART OF THE CHILDREN'S
INITIATIVE NOW IT'S PARK. IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
OUR NEW. TERMS YOU KNOW- TERMS
OF ART IN PROFESSIONAL TERMS IN
THE TERMS OF WHERE WE NEED TO
GO. I JUST MUCH LIKE YOU SENATOR
LAYERED AND ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT MEANS
SOMETHING AND THAT IT IS
CONNECTED SO. I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES BECAUSE I REALLY
REALLY THINK- IT SHOWS THAT YOU
ARE WORKING TOWARDS MAKING THIS
PLAN- AND IMPLEMENTING IT ARE
MANY OF US THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
SAW ALL OF THE COMMENTS YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT THE LACK OF
SERVICES OR THIS ORGANIZATION OR
THE INTEGRATION. WE GOT TO SEE
FRONT AND CENTRE WHAT THE IMPACT
WAS ON SENIORS WHETHER THEY BE
EN- SOME TYPE OF CARE FACILITY
NURSING HOME OR IN HOME TRYING
TO STAY CONNECTED TO THE OUTSIDE
WORLD. DESPITE THE RISK AND A
NUMBER OF US HAD SITUATIONS
WHERE FAMILY MEMBERS NEEDED TO
COUNT ON IN HOME HEALTH
SERVICES. OF FOR VARIOUS REASONS
AND SO. I JUST APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND YOUR
EXPERTISE SO- BUT BUT IT ALL TO
SAY WE WILL BE TALKING WITH YOU
AGAIN IN ANOTHER VENUE TO ASK.
ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ASKED. WHAT MORE CAN
WE DO AND HOW WHAT IS THE PLAN
FOR HOW WE DO IT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE SERVICES ARE ON THE
GROUND- SO I JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR COMMENTS. TODAY AND
YOU'RE ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS
WITH THE DEATH AND THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU HAVE TO DO THAT. SO-
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BECAUSE-
THEY EXPENDED ALL THE QUESTIONS
AND I GOT TO DO MY- COMMENT TO
EVERY SINGLE. QUESTION THEY ASK
. BUT THIS IS IMPORTANT- IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I HAVE A
BIRTHDAY COMING UP- YEAH. AND
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT OUR
SENIORS BUT I MIGHT SUGGEST THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF US SITTING
HERE THAT MEET THAT DEFINITION
MAYBE NOT YOU SENATOR CALM
WATER. BUT BUT A FEW OF US A FEW
OF US. AND SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THEM BEFORE TALKING ABOUT
US. YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR HAD A
HILARIOUS EXPERIENCE WHERE. MY
MOTHER MOVED INTO A FIFTY FIVE
AN OLDER MOBILE HOME PARK BEFORE
SHE'S AN ASSISTED LIVING AND SHE
SAID THIS IS SO WONDERFUL WHEN
WITH PEOPLE MY OWN AGE AND I
SAID MOM ALL THREE OF YOUR SONS
COULD LIVE HERE. NOT DAWNED ON
HER. YOU KNOW I CONTINUE SAY
THIS IS. US SO I APPRECIATE THIS
WORK IT'S SO CRITICAL BECAUSE OF
OUR AGING- COPULATION- BACK TO
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS ARE
ALL SENATORS HAVEN'T COMPLETED
THEIR QUESTIONING AND COMMENTS-
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO A TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT MAY
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
MR MORRIS. AND I INVITE YOU
FORWARD IF ANYONE IS HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AND I
ACTUALLY SEE TWO PEOPLE. AND I
WOULD JUST ASK- THREE. I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT YOU KEEP THE
PROPER DISTANCING PLEASE COME ON
FORWARD. I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF
ANY AND VERY BRIEF COMMENTS AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE NASA KICKING ON BEHALF OF
KELSEY'S THE STATEWIDE SOCIAIS
ASIAN. A PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF INNOCENT
AMERISOURCEBERGEN FORMATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
AND TRULY BELIEVE THAT SHE'S THE
LEADER TO BRING TOGETHER ALL OF
THESE ANTI DOES
INTERDISCIPLINARY DEPARTMENTS TO
REALLY. MAKE THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING A TRULY SUCCESSFUL EFFORT
THE NO WRONG DOOR IS IMPORTANT
TO US TOO. MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE CAPACITY BUT HAVE NOT
REACHED A MOMENT YET WE WANT TO
BE THERE FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE. ONE STRONG
SUPPORTER FOR NOMINATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
I'LL. WELCOMETO THE NEXT
WITNESS. SACRAMENTO CHAIRMAN.
BEVERLY BEHALF OF U. D. W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT MISTER
MORRIS'S CONFIRMATION GIVEN HER
DEDICATION EXPERTISE OF CARE
GIVING AN AGING ISSUES. WE
APPRECIATE HER LONGSTANDING WORK
TO PLAN TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
GROWING POPULATION OF OLDER
ADULTSAND TO HELP ADDRESS
WORKFORCE ISSUES AS WELL AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER
IN THIS NEW CAPACITY. AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY OF THIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WHEN I ASK IF I'M
HERE. OKAY GREAT READY MADE
ARRANGEMENTS TO. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
DAN OPENS US AND I AM THE PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE'RE
HERE EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SUSAN TOMORROW TOMORROW IS
TO SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR CDA AND
CAN'T SPEAK- HIGHLY ABOUT HER A
EVEN HIGHER THAN WE ALREADY DONE
BEFORE- SHE'S GOT INSTANT
CREDIBILITY WITHIN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY FOR HER
EXPERTISE ST FORT ASSESSMENT
ISSUES EXPERIENCE BACKGROUND-
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH THE THIS IS DEMERIT MORRIS
OVER THE YEARS AND I DON'T SEE
HOW THE ONGOING SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA'S UP. TWENTY FIVE
INTENT LIVING CENTERS BUT MANY-
ALLIES WITH PEOPLE'S
DISABILITIES AND FOR ALSO WE ONE
PLOTTER FOR LEADERSHIP IN
GUIDING THE MASTER PLAN AGING-
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT AND ALSO
THE WORK IN STRENGTHENING OUR
CALIFORNIA'S NETWORK OF- ADR
SEES OR AGING DISABILITY
RESOURCE CENTERS SO WE HAVE
WE'RE JUST SO GLAD TO HAVE A
REPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT TESTIMONY
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY SEEING NO MORE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE- I SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY SAID THIS BUT LET ME PUT
BACK UP THE TOLL FREE NUMBER.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ONE AND WITH THAT LET ME
WELCOME OUR MODERATOR FOR TODAY
TO PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS IN Q.
PEOPLE UP TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. YOU'RE USING
A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. SPECIALIST WILL THEN
GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
FISHING BACKING HIM ONCE AGAIN
MATTER THE ONE THANK ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND WE GOT ABOUT FIVE
IN Q. AND LOCAL TO LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN C. OR HAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. OKAY VERY LOS
ANGELES. YEAH VERY MUCH HE
STRONG SUPPORT AND COMPENSATION-
ON LINE. VIRUS AMHERST OKAY HE
THANK YOU CONFIRM HER THANK YOUR
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF- NEXT
WITNESS. MY NUMBER FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION COUNTY WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION OF STUDENT OF OURS IS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
EIGHTEEN. SHE HAS A WEALTH OF
EXPERIENCE IN ASIAN POLICY AND
LEADERSHIP RETIREMENT
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AND
ROLLED ON THE GOVERNOR'S
ALZHEIMER'S TASK FORCE TO
MATTHEW PLANT THEY CALL IT AS
YOU COMMITTEE I WITH HER
KNOWLEDGE ON ASIAN ISSUES
UNDERSTAND THE KEY ROLE THAT
COUNTY HAVE THE DELIVERY AGENT
SERVICES. AND COLLABORATIVE WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS NATION
COMMUNITY MISTER MORRISON STRONG
CHOICE TO LEAD. THE PARTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITH. YES TO A LOCAL I. NUMBER
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON YES MEAN COED- IN YOUR
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH JUSTICE IN
AGING CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HIS IN THE MERITS OF
CONFIRMATION FOR DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AGING. AN
AGING WORK WITH AMERICA FOR MANY
YEARS IN A PREVIOUS ROLE AT THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WHERE WE
KNEW HER TO BE A COMMITTED AND
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF OLDER
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
LIVING WITH DEMENTIA AND
ALZHEIMER'S. POLICY EXPERT WHO
IS LASER FOCUSED ON
UNDERSTANDING HOW POLICY IMPACTS
THE DAILY LIVES OF PEOPLE
STREET- SHE'S EXTREMELY WELL
RESPECTED BY THE ASIAN COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA AND HER
APPOINTMENT HAS BEEN GREETED
WITH SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WHY NUMBER TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI HEATHER HARRISON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE DIFFERENCES
CONFIRMATION AS DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF AGING I WORK WITH
STUDENTS FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AND NOW WITHOUT A DOUBT
BUT SHE IS THE RIGHT PERSON TO
LEAD THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF AGING SHE IS SMART-
COMPASSIONATE LEADER AND HAS. TO
BE REALLY A CREATIVE PROBLEM
SOLVER IS MANAGED SPENT HER
CAREER FOCUSED ON IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND-
WE ARE WILL ALL BE LUCKY TO HAVE
HER IN A PERFECT POSITION MY
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARMENTA MODERATOR OTHER
WITNESSES. WE HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. AMERICA FLYING NUMBER EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR MY NAME IS DANNY PARKER
MARTIN NINE THAT PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF LEADING H. CALIFORNIA THE
STATE'S ONLY ASSOCIATION THAT
FOCUSES ON THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM
ABOUT OUT OF HOSPITAL. AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
INCLUDING SENIOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LIFE PLAN COMMUNITY
CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY HOME HEALTH HOSPICE OF
CAPE PROVIDERS. ARE NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS SERVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF OLDER ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT LEADING
EIGHT CALIFORNIA WORKING CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND ALL CAL
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MARK
AND HER MOST RECENT FORMER WALL
AT THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
AND ALSO I THINK H<c.cyan>EMBER OF</c>
THE MASTER PLAN BREAKING
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
LEADERSHIP AND COLLECTIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF EIGHTEEN
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ABILITY TO INTEGRATE THE
NEEDS OF CONSUMERS FAMILY CARE
DIRECTLY AND PROVIDERS. AND OUT
IN EVERY CONVERSATION MEETING
AND WRITTEN DOCUMENTS THESE
ATTRIBUTES HAVE ELEVATED
STUDENTS ONE OF CALIFORNIA HE
VOICES AND LEADERS FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT AND URGES YOU TO CAN.
MARK AS- A AN AGING THANK. YOU
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES. AND
WE DO NOT ANYMORE IN YOU FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A FEW
MINUTES MADAME MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR
ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION- SO LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH- THE MICROPHONE IN THE
DYESS OF META MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU NOW TO
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WOULD WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. VIA
TELECONFERENCE. THE GENTLEMAN
FOR YOUR ARE IN THE POLLS. THE
ISSUE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
MATTAPONI WONDERING VERO. I'M
SURE WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT LATER
IN THE HEARING. LET ME SEE IF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR ARE READY TO MAKE A
MOTION. MADAM VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE MOTION- LET
ME ASK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI I BATES
BATES AYE ATKINS FIVE INSIDE ON
COLD THIS WILL BE ON CALL MR
MARS DAMORE'S BCAUSE ARE WE
HAVE ONE MEMBER WHO STILL AND
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT- WE
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
THIS- APPOINTMENT TO FULL
CONFIRMATION OF THE SENATE WITH
OUR CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR ATKINS AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD REST
OF YOUR DAY. I'M GONNA LOOK TO
SEE IF WE NEED TO TAKE A SHORT
BREAK- BEFORE WE GO TO THE NEXT
. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
FORWARD. JUST CHECKING IN WITH
OUR INCREDIBLE COURT REPORTER.
SO WE WILL. NOW MOVES TO ITEM
ONE B. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
NICOLE ES ELLIOTT AS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. LET ME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- DIRECTOR ELLIOTT-
OFFER YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE. ARE ALSO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS AND REMARKS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE AND THEN AFTER THAT
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY FOR YOU AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF MY APPOINTMENT
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR PLACING HIS TRUST
IN ME WHEN SELECTING NEED FOR
THIS APPOINTMENT. WITH ME TODAY
IN SPIRIT IS MY TWO YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER LUCY AND MY PARTNER J.
SENT. BOTH OF WHOM I LOVE DEEPLY
AND WHO KEEP ME MOTIVATED TO
WORK EVERY DAY TO MAKE THIS
WORLD BETTER FOR OUR NEXT
GENERATION. IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ASKED TO SERVE CALIFORNIA IN
THIS CAPACITY AND TO DO SO AT
SUCH A FORMATIVE TIME. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. LESS THAN A
YEAR AFTER VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR MAYOR ED
LEE ASKED ME TO SERVE AS SAN
FRANCISCO'S INAUGURAL DIRECTOR
OF THE LOCAL OFFICES CANNABIS.
IN THIS ROLE I LED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
LOCAL REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
THE TRANSITION LEGACY OPERATORS
TO THE LEGAL MARKET AS WELL AS
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S EARLY EQUITY
PROGRAMS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN I
WAS ASKED TO SERVE AS THE
GOVERNOR'S SENIOR ADVISER ON
CANNABIS WITH THE GOAL OF
IMPROVING AND REFINING
CALIFORNIA'S ADMINISTRATION OF
THE MEDICAL AND ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATION AND SAFETY
ACT. THAT SAME YEAR I LED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
ASSESS THE CANNABIS FRAMEWORK
AND LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
LARGE SCALE IMPROVEMENTS SUCH AS
THE CONSOLIDATION OF THE THREE
LEGACY PROGRAMS. THE CENTRALIZED
OUR EFFORTS AND CREATE ONE
UNIFIED POINT OF CONTACT FOR ALL
LICENSEES IN STAKEHOLDERS. TAKEN
TOGETHER THESE EXPERIENCES
UNIQUELY QUALIFY ME TO SERVE AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROLS DIRECTOR. AS AN
ORGANIZATION OUR VISION IS TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA HAS A STATE
THE STATE OF ALL AN EQUITABLE
CANNABIS MARKET THAT SERVES AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR THE WORLD. I HAVE
WASTED NO TIME IN WORKING
TOWARDS THIS GOAL ALONGSIDE THE
INCREDIBLE STAFF OF THIS
DEPARTMENT. INCLUDING DEVELOPING
MECHANISMS TO MEASURE OUR
PROGRESS AND SUCCESS. I KNOW
THAT THERE IS STILL MUCH TO BE
DONE TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSITION TO THAT WELL
REGULATED SUSTAINABLE AND
EQUITABLE LEGAL MARKET WE ALL
WANT TO SEE. AS DIRECTOR IS
CONFIRMED I COMMIT TO LEADING
THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO MEET THIS
OBJECTIVE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SMART AND
COMPREHENSIVE. REGULATORY SYSTEM
BY PURSUING SOLUTIONS THAT
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE BARRIERS
CANNABIS OPERATORS FACE AN
IMPROVING COORDINATION WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS. LASTLY I AM
COMMITTED TO MEETING THIS WORK
WITH INCLUSIVITY SO THAT THE
LUCIANS WE DEVELOP ARE NOT JUST
EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE AND
TRANSPARENT AS WELL. I WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR TAKING OUT MY
APPOINTMENT TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CENTER LAYERED YOU
WANNA KICK US OFF. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. IN THANK YOU MADAM
DIRECTOR FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE AND FOR MEETING WITH ME-
TO HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE SUBJECT
AND I THINK- I'D LIKE TO. TO ASK
A COUPLE OF GLOBAL QUESTIONS AND
ONE IS THAT. THERE IS BEEN THE
GRADUAL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BALLOT MEASURE AND THERE HAS
BEEN THE COMBINATION. OF FIVE
AGENCIES TO BECOME THE
DEPARTMENT- JUST- WHAT ARE THE
PRESSING ISSUES IN IN SORT OF
FOR MAKING THIS. OUR. JUST
INDUSTRY WE GOAL ARE LICENSED
AND AVAILABLE ONE WAY THAT THAT
IN COMPETING WITH THE
UNDERGROUND INDUSTRY IT WORKS
BETTER TO COME ABOVE GROUND AND
BE REGULATED. SO I THINK THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF PRESSING ISSUES-
THE INDUSTRY ITSELF IS IN A
TRANSITION AYE WE'RE SEEING A
NUMBER OF OPERATORS I HAD MOVED
FROM THE LEGACY MARKET INTO THE
LEGAL MARKET- AND THAT
FACILITATE CONSOLIDATED BY IT A
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
CREATING REGULATED PATHWAYS FOR
THOSE OPERATORS TO BECOME
LEGITIMATE HOWEVER WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO HAVE NOT
YET CREATED THOSE PATHWAYS. SO I
WOULD SAY THAT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT- OUTSTANDING COMPONENT
THAT REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT I'M IN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP THEM I'M
ESTABLISH THOSE PATHWAYS AND
CREATE. WE CAN CREATE THOSE
PATHWAYS FOR LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES THAT SO THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENT. I'M
ASIDE FROM THAT AS THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW ESTABLISHED
AND STABILIZED- AS WE LOOK AT
OUR WORK I HAD A SIGNIFICANT
PRIORITY FOR US IS READ REDUCING
COSTS. OF PARTICIPATION IN THE
LEGAL MARKET I'M WITHIN OUR
CONTROL IS TO LOOK AT OUR
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK AND FIGURE
OUT HOW. WE CAN STILL MEET THE
OBJECTIVES OF THAT FRAMEWORK
WOULD DO SO IN A WAY THAT
REDUCES THE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
THAT A NUMBER OF OPERATORS
PARTICULARLY SMALL LEGACY
INEQUITY OPERATORS. ON FACE SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW- I CAN
LESSEN ANYMORE BUT I THINK THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE TOP OF MIND
PRIORITIES. I APPRECIATE THAT
MORE MADE DRIED OUT A LITTLE. I
HAVE ONE OF THOSE DISTRICTS
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF CANNABIS
GROWN AND THERE'S BIG SERVER
THERE'S A LEGACY SMALL OUTDOOR
FARMERS AND THEN. IT MONTEREY
COUNTY GIVE PRIORITY TO
GREENHOUSES AND AS A RESULT
THAT'S WHERE. THERE IS A LOT
GOING AND I VISITED A GREENHOUSE
SOUTH OF CHU ARE COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO. AND THE PRICES HAVE PLUNGED
BELOW WHAT IS IN ESSENCE THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS THEN. IF
THERE PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM.
MAKING A CALCULATION TO COME
INSIDE THAT DOESN'T. TOTALLY
WORK AND I KNOW WHEN OUR
CONVERSATION. THERE WERE A WHOLE
HOST OF ISSUES THERE WAS THE
ISSUE OF HAVING ENOUGH PLACES TO
SELL THE PRODUCT TO MAKE IT A
COMPLETE CYCLE. THERE WERE WERE
ISSUES OF TAXATION AND WHETHER
OR NOT. EVERY DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
TAXATION MAKES IT HARD TO
COMPETE THROUGH THE LEGAL
SYSTEM. ARE THERE THINGS IN IN
THOSE CATEGORIES THAT YOU MIGHT
ADDRESS YOU'VE WE SHOULD ADDRESS
TO MAKE SURE WE ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO COME WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. SO YOUR POINT ABOUT
MARKET HEALTH I THINK IS THE
FIRST ONE OUT THERE IS
CHALLENGES ACROSS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN WE HAVE ENORMOUS
PRODUCTION CAPACITY BUT THERE
ARE NOT SIGNIFICANT OR I SHOULD
SAY SUFFICIENT OUTPUTS OUT FOR
CONSUMERS TO ACCESS SAFE TESTED
REGULATED PRODUCTS. SO THERE
DOES NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF
WORK RELATED TO I'M BALANCING-
THE MARKET THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT OUTPUT SO THAT
CONSUMERS CAN HAVE SAFE ACCESS.
ONTO YOUR QUESTION ABOT TAX
REFORM YES I THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT IT LOOKS I KNOW THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS VERY FOCUSED
ON THAT ISSUE- EVIDENCED BY THE
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD. WELL WE ARE
NOT. THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF IS
NOT- THE TAX EXPERTS WHERE WE
ARE APPROPRIATELY SITUATED TO
WEIGH IN ON TAX REFORM IS THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT THE TAX
STRUCTURE. PLACES ARE LICENSEES
I'M AND AS IT STANDS TODAY THAT
TAX STRUCTURE IS INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX- AND CREATES AN-
ADMINISTRATION CHALLENGES FOR
OUR LICENSEES AS WE SEE THAT TAX
I'LL BE BACK. THIS IS A CHANGE
I'M IN IT CAN HAVE. MORE
CHALLENGES ON A SMALLER
OPERATORS INTO YOUR DISTRICTS
SENATOR I'M IT HAS SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES ON IT IS REALLY CUTE
WE FELT BY- OUTDOOR SMALL
FILTERS SO WE DO BELIEVE THE
ISSUE OF TAX REFORM IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE OUT. THIS
YEAR WE THINK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR
FOCUS ON THAT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING A TECHNICAL
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO GET
SOMETHING ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
THANK YOU- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
ESTABLISHING A NEW INDUSTRIES-
LAUGHTER. I DID A BILL OF THIS
DEVICE THE STANDARDS SO THAT
THEY WERE PROTESTING ACROSS THE
STATE IN THIS YEAR THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAVE TO DO SICK
WHILE MULTIPLE MULTIPLE TIMES
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE TO DO ONCE.
ARE IN THIS AND I'M TRYING TO DO
THAT THIS. YEAR MORE QUESTIONS.
I KNOW THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAVE AN
AND FOR. TO AS PART OF THE- AND-
ONE OF THE- THINGS WHEN I WAS
RESOURCES SECRETARY. IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WOULD PARTICIPATE WITH LOCAL
SHERIFFS AND OTHER PEOPLE AND
THERE WERE ISSUES OF. EXCESSIVE
USE OF PESTICIDES WE WOULDN'T
ALLOW ANYWHERE ELSE MASSIVE
DIVERSIONS OF WATER. PEOPLE WITH
GUNS THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
LICENSED ARE THERE WERE ALL
THESE ISSUES INDEED FOR SMIT IN
ONE OF THE REASONS I THOUGHT IT
WAS GOOD TO HAVE THE BALLOT
MEASURES LIKE WHAT'S BRINGING IN
HOUSE REGULATED NO PESTICIDES NO
WATER DIVERSIONS THAT THOSE KIND
OF THINGS. YOU'RE HAVING TO
STAND UP ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
THAT I THINK YOU TOLD ME IT WAS
EIGHTY PEOPLE OR SOMETHING HOW'S
THAT GOING HOW'S THAT WORKING
WHAT KIND OF CASES OR ACTIONS.
DO YOU UNDERTAKE OR SPECTER
UNDERTAKE THROUGH NINE FORCING A
DIVISION. YES WE DO HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS COMPRISED OF
I BELIEVE SEVENTY SEVEN SWORN
OFFICERS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED WE
HAVE. A FIFTY SEVEN CURRENTLY
HIRED- THAT ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
DOES FOCUS ON CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY. OUT WE ALSO
HAVE INDIVIDUALS I WITHIN OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION WHO FOCUSED
ON SUPPORTING- OUR ENFORCEMENT
RELATED TO. HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. PRODUCTION OF LEGAL
PRODUCTION THAT HAS NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS TO THE
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THE
WATER BOARD. I'M IN THOSE
COMPLIANCE STAFF SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CIVIL
PENALTIES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
ACTIVITY SO WE TAKE SORT OF A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH- BUT OUR
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OFF FROM
THAT FROM THE CULTIVATION SIDE
GENERALLY TENDS TO SUPPORT I C.
F. W. AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO. THE
RATIFICATION OF CAMPUS PLANTS
ARE SO FOCUSED ENFORCEMENT ON
ILLEGAL CULTIVATION ANY LEGAL
CULTIVATION THAT IS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING THE ENVIRONMENT. THANK
YOU- APPRECIATE YOUR BEARING
WITH MY QUESTIONS AND ONCE AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE AND- IN
EVEN THOUGH I. KNOW WE'RE STILL
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU
WORKING TOGETHER AND ALL THESE
EFFORTS. HIS LETTER. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED SENATOR COME
MARKER. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEMAN- THANK YOU IT WAS ALSO-
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
EARLIER THIS WEEK TO MEET AND
CHAT WITH ME I AM HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY I'M GONNA TRY
AND FOCUS MY QUESTIONS- IN.
AROUND THE EQUITY FEE WAIVER
PROGRAM- SPACE SO I WHEN WE
TALKED I SHARED WITH YOU- THAT I
AM EXCITED ABOUT A LOCAL
BUSINESS THAT IS IN MY DISTRICT
ACTUALLY IN THE HEART OF THE
THIRTY EIGHTH- THE GROW OUR OUR
X. CANNABIS- STORE RUN BY KIKI A
SISTER WHO REALLY SHARED HER.
ELABORATE EXPERIENCE TRYING TO
GET TO THE PLACE WHERE SHE'S
ABLE TO OPEN THIS AMAZING
FACILITY AND THE SUPPORT THAT
SHE HAS FROM ALL OF US TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT STAYS OPEN BUT OF
COURSE IN THE PROCESS OF
LEARNING ABOUT HER JOURNEY. YOU
DO HEAR ABOUT- THE CHALLENGES
THAT FOLKS HAVE WITH THE FE
WAIVER PROGRAM AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE KNOW THAT
IT HAS BEEN PROBLEMATIC IN SOME
WAYS. SO IT WOULD BE. JUST SORT
OF SHARE ARM YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
REQUIRING IMPROVEMENT IN THE
EMERGENCY CANNABIS EQUITY. FEE
WAIVER REGULATIONS AND HOW THESE
ISSUES ARE BEING OR HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED. ABSOLUTELY SO THE FEE
WAIVER PROGRAM WHICH WAS- HAVE A
PROGRAM A PORTION OF THAT. AND
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE- SHORTLY AFTER THE
BUDGET AS SEASON LAST LAST YEAR.
WAS FOR THE DEPARTMENT WE WERE
REQUIRED TO PUT IN PLACE I
THROUGH URGENCY REGULATIONS IF
YOU EVER PROGRAM BY JANUARY
FIRST- AND IN DOING THAT THROUGH
THE EMERGENCY REGULATION PROCESS
WE DID HERE I SENATOR TO YOUR
POINT CONCERNS RELATED TO A
COUPLE OF COMPONENTS I
SPECIFICALLY OF THAT PROGRAM.
AND THE FIRST BEING THE BRIDE
APPLICATION OF GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATIONS THAT WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT PROGRAM AND THE SECOND
BEING THE GROSS RECEIPTS CAP ON
NOTED LEAST FOR RETAILERS OR-
ACTUALLY ALL LICENSEES ACROSS
THE STATE IN JURISDICTIONS. OUT
WHERE IT WAS. IT REQUIRES MORE
CAPITAL TO DO BUSINESS- AND WE
HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WITH MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
ON THOSE POLICIES ON THE
PREFERENCES WE ANTICIPATE MAKING
MODIFICATIONS. YOU ARE FEE
WAIVER PROGRAM. THROUGH OUR
EMERGENCY REGULATION WE ADOPT
WHICH WE HOPE TO DO SHORTLY IT
IS THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS WAY. TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES AND THEN
DOING ADDITIONAL OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT AS WE GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR RULEMAKING PROCESS FOR
THE FEE WAIVER PROGRAM I'M IN
THE LONG RUN AS WELL AS THE
DEFERRAL PROGRAM WHICH IS
STATUTORILY MANDATED TO COME ON
NINETEEN RIGHT FIRST. OF NEXT
YEAR. GREAT- YOU MENTIONED ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES BEING SORT OF
THE BROAD APPLICATION OF THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS AND SO
CURRENTLY AND ELIGIBILITY FOR
FEE WAIVERS IS BASED ON AN APPLE
CAN'T LIVING IN A
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
AREA- THAT IS OVERBROAD. I'M IN
DATA FROM THE STATE LIBRARIAN
SHOWS THAT THIS DEFINITION
ENCOMPASSES ABOUT 80% OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE WHO COULD
THEORETICALLY QUALIFY. FOR THE
FEE WAIVER PROGRAM. SO I'D LOVE
IT IF YOU COULD JUST DROP DOWN A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFICALLY ON
HOW YOU PLAN TO EITHER NARROW
THE ELIGIBILITY IN THIS CARE OF
THE CATEGORIES SO THAT- THE
INTENT OF THE STATUE IS MEANT.
ABSOLUTELY YES. SO REALLY
LOOKING AT ASTON DISTRACTS
SPECIFICALLY SO WITHIN I'M
IDENTIFIED COUNTIES HI AND IT A.
M. I. LEVELS WITHIN THOSE CENSUS
TRACTS AS WELL AS- I BELIEVE
GRADUATION RATES- BUT I AM HAPPY
TO CIRCLE BACK ON THAT SPECIFIC
POINT- SEVERELY NARROWING IT
TOO. HIGH CENSUS TRACTS WHERE
YOU'VE SEEN THE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THE WAR ON DRUGS
IMPACTING AND THE COMMUNITY
BROADLY- SO THAT WILL NARROW IT
AS WELL AS THE APPLICATION OF
ARREST. OR CONVICTION FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL OR A MEMBER OF THEIR
FAMILY. I SO REALLY LOOKING AT
THOSE TWO CRITERIA WHICH ARE
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA WITHIN THE
PAST FEW THREE WAIVER PROGRAMS
I'M AS ADDITIONAL WAYS TO NARROW
THAT APPLICATION SO THAT WE ARE
APPROPRIATELY CHARLIE TARGETING.
THESE IN FINITE DOLLARS TOWARDS
INDIVIDUALS. FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS. GREAT THANK
YOU YOU KNOW AND IN MY CLASS IS
VERY BROAD BASED ONE I BECAUSE I
AM NOW THINKING BACK TO THE-
HEARING I HAD ON A CANNABIS TAX
REFORM AND WE HAD A REALLY GOOD
A STRONG ARM. DIVERSE GROUP OF
PANELISTS TO KIND OF TALK ABOUT
THE INS AND THE OUTS OF CANNABIS
ACROSS THE STATE FROM
CULTIVATION AND PRODUCTION TO
DISTRIBUTION AND- RETAIL AND
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN DO BETTER I
THINK YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT-
YOU KNOW IT SEEMED LIKE THIS WAS
GOING TO BE MANNA FROM HEAVEN
AND YET WE'RE STILL SORT OF. IN
THIS LOG TRYING TO FIND. A
BALANCE. FOR WHAT WE WERE
EXPECTING AND HOPING FROM
LEGALIZING CANNABIS IN THE
REALITIES THAT WERE IN. AND THEN
IN THE MIDST OF ALL THAT
DISCUSSIONS AROUND EQUITY. SO
FOR YOU WHAT DOES CANNOT BE
CANNABIS EQUITY LOOK LIKE. FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
FUTURE. WHAT IS ADEQUATE CAMPUS
EQUITY LOOK LIKE I THINK IT
LOOKS AT LIKE A DIVERSE MARKET
LIKE OWNERS WHO ARE ABLE TO.
OWNERS WHO HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
EITHER BY THE STATE OR BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS HAVING BEEN
NEGATIVELY. AND DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS I'M
REALIZING ACTUAL OWNERSHIP IN
THOSE BUSINESSES AND GENERATING
GENERATIONAL WEALTH I THINK IT
ALSO MEANS A DIVERSE WORKFORCE-
THOSE TWO THINGS I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND REFLECTED
IN THE NUMBER OF LOCAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE. I'M HAS STARTED TO EXPAND
ALBION'S AS THOSE LOCAL PROGRAMS
IN PART TO THAT FEE WAIVER
PROGRAM SO REALLY A DIVERSE
MARKET. GREAT WELL YOU KNOW
THANK YOU FOR THAT I JUST WANT
TO CONTINUE TO ECHO- AND THIS IS
NOT ALL PLACED ON YOU BUT YOU
ARE HERE. THAT- WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ALL WORK TOGETHER THE
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE THIS
SPACE AND MEANINGFUL TO EVERYONE
WHO IS INTERESTED BECAUSE UNTIL
WE DO THAT THERE WILL STILL BE
AN UNREGULATED MARKET THAT IS
THRIVING BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE INTERESTED IN. ALL
OF THE HOOPS THAT WE ARE ASKING
THEM TO JUMP THROUGH TO OPEN UP
A BUSINESS. AND REALLY SORT OF
MAINTAIN IT ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
ANY KIND OF SUPPORT SO ME AND I
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT. YOU
KNOW- YOU KNOW FEDERAL.
REGULATIONS AND BANKING WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT LIABILITY
AND SECURITY WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT HOW FOLKS STILL HAVE TO DO
A LOT OF THIS USING CASH- BUT
ALL THOSE ARE STILL STRUGGLES.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES BETWEEN THE NORTH AND
THE SOUTH AS IT RELATES TO
CULTIVATION WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW THE CITIES
AND THE COUNTIES WORK TOGETHER
WHEN YOU HAVE SOME PORTION OF
THE BUSINESS IN ONE SPACE AND
THEN ANOTHER PORTION AND THE
OTHER. AND ULTIMATELY. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CONSUMER. THE PERSON
WHO JUST WANTS WHAT THEY WANT
AND THEY WANT IT FOR A REALLY
GOOD PRICE AND THEY DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT ALL OF THE- SAUSAGE
MAKING- AND IF IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S TOO ARDUOUS THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
SAUSAGE MAKING- AND SO. YOU HAVE
A LARGE TASK AHEAD OF YOU. TO
SORT ALL OF THAT OUT- AND I AM
CERTAINLY WISHING YOU LUCK.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
SENATOR COME AUTOMATIC VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU THANK YOU ON
MANAGER- AND WE HAD A VERY- IN
DEPTH ROBUST DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY WE COVERED A LOT I IN
PARTICULAR IN THE ENFORCEMENT
AREA DIRECTOR ELIA AND I WAS
VERY PLEASED WITH YOUR RESPONSES
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES JUST
WENT A LITTLE DEEPER INTO THE
ENFORCEMENT A QUESTION REGARDING
THE ACTUAL CRIMINAL. CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT DOWN THE OF
THE LICENSING ISSUE ARE AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS VERY ENGAGE WITH
THAT I JUST LIKE TO TAKE A FEW
MINUTES- IN AGAIN RETURN TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AUTHORITY
WITHOUT REGARD TO REGULATING
CANNABIS BUSINESSES IN THEIR
JURISDICTION. AND WE TOUCHED A
LITTLE BIT ON IT YESTERDAY IN
THE DISCUSSION THAT I DIDN'T GET
A FEELING THAT YOU HAVE- I
GUESS. KNOWLEDGE BEYOND JUST THE
PRESENT AS TO WHETHER THERE WILL
BE SOME SORT OF PRESSURE FOR
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENT THAT
PROHIBITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FROM HAVING SOME AUTHORITY OVER
A CANNABIS ACTIVITIES IN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND COULD YOU. JUST
GIVE A ON YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT IN THE PRESENT IN WHAT
MIGHT BE. GOING FORWARD BECAUSE
OF THAT IS. SIGNIFICANT IN MY
DISTRICT THOSE IN PARTICULAR I
HAVE TO. THAT DO ALLOW IT- AND
THEN THE BALANCE OF WRESTLING
WITH IT AND HAVE A LOT TO DO
WITH ACCESS I THINK I'D
MENTIONED THAT TO YOU WHEN WE
WERE. MEETING YESTERDAY- HAVING
TO DO WITH THE MANNER IN WHICH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUCTURED
WITH ACCESS IN PARTICULAR TO
SCHOOLS. ANNA IN PARTICULAR
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOLS
SEEM TO BE ALL ON THE SAME
ROUTES IN A VERY SHORT. DISTANCE
AND ALL SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY AND
CERTAINLY IN NORTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WHICH ENCOMPASSES MY
DISTRICT. SO I JUST HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THAT QUESTION AND GET
AGAIN YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR. AS I SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YESTERDAY AND AS I INDICATED IN
OUR CONVERSATION I'M AS A LOCAL
HAS A FORMER LOCAL REGULATOR I
CAN SYMPATHIZE. WITH THOSE
CONCERNS- WHEN WE DEVELOPED OUR
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO I WE DID SO WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS WANTING TO- HAVE
SOME CONTROL AND OVERSIGHT AND
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE BUSINESSES
THAT WERE OPERATING IN OUR
COMMUNITY- AND WE FELT THAT THAT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT. TO US AS A
CITY AND WE WERE NOT CLEAR HOW
THE STATE I WOULD SUPPORT US IN
THAT EFFORT SO WE CREATED OUR
OWN CONTROLS AND MECHANISMS TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSE OBJECTIVES. I'M
ON THE STATE LEVEL NOW I'LL WHAT
WE HAVE WITHIN OUR CONTROL AS A
DEPARTMENT. I IS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT SHOULD
THEY WISH TO PROVIDE. LEGITIMATE
PATHWAYS FOR BUSINESSES TO
OPERATE WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS HI INCLUDING
THROUGH PROVIDING THEM WITH MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE IN THEIR JURISDICTION-
WHETHER THAT BE RELATED TO THEIR
LICENSING- BACKGROUND OR OVERALL
COMPLIANCE. THROUGH THINGS LIKE
TRACK AND TRACE DATA SO THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT LIKE I SAID OUR
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT'S CONTROL
AND AREAS WHERE WE STAND READY
WILLING. TO SUPPORT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ON THAT JOURNEY
ANSWERED THROUGH THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THOSE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU AND I THINK THAT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT KINDA IS
SOMETHING ISSUE LAYING AND
WAITING FOR A FUTURE PROBABLY
ROBUST DISCUSSION AT THE STATE
LEVEL BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS. OUR TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE CERTAINLY I'M MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IN MANY OF THE
CITIES AND MY DISTRICT THEIR
CONTRACT WITH THE SHERIFF. IN
THOSE COSTS GO UP ANNUALLY SO
HAVING A SPECIFIC. ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OVERSEEING
WHAT WOULD BE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AND SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES I THINK IS WHAT
WEIGHS HEAVILY ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A MIND IN AGAIN OF
COURSE THE ACCESS TO- THE YOUTH-
IT WOULD PROBABLY. BE A
SIGNIFICANT ONE TWO THAT JUST
PUTTING ON THE RECORD I THINK IT
WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT THAT
STANDARDS IF THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT EVENTUALLY GAPS
TO. OUR MORE DISCRETION-
REQUIRED BY THE STATE- I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
STANDARDS ARE SET FORWARD ON
WHAT EVIDENCE BASED WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ALLOW- THAT- LACK OF
OVERSIGHT OR LACK OF ABILITY TO
APPROVE OR DISAPPROVE THAT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO WITHOUT
HAVING BUT I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR KNOWLEDGE VERY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR YOUR ENERGY
IN PATTERSON PASSION TO PURSUE
OF THE FOB. NEW ADVENTURE IN ON
YOUR CAREER YOU WILL HAVE MY
SUPPORT OF FOUR YEAR-
CONFIRMATION AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR TAKING TIME THE VERY BUSY
THERE YOU YEAH YES ALL. RESHAPE
THE TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR- AND I
WOULD AGREE WITH MICHAEL
OBVIOUSLY. THE DEATH OF YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE ON A
VERY COMPLICATED- PROGRAM AN
ISSUE GIVEN THE LOCAL AND THE
STATE- DIFFERING ROLES. I AM I
DON'T THINK I HAVE MUCH TO ADD
NEW WAVE QUESTIONS IS ALWAYS THE
BENEFIT OF GOING LAST BUT- I DO
WANT TO UNDERSCORE WHAT SENATOR
CALM WATER SAID AND YOU WERE NOT
SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT WE HAVE.
OBVIOUSLY COLLEAGUES WITHIN THE
SENATE THAT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT THE EQUITY. OUT WAIVERS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS IN A
WAY THAT IS- WELL EQUITABLE I AM
I'M FOLLOW UP AT ANOTHER TIME I
I'VE LOOKED PARTICULARLY AT THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND PROGRAM
- LOCAL JURISDICTIONS GRANT
FUNDING AND I AND I REALLY FOUND
YOU KNOW I'M I'M LOOKING TO WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND THAT AND I MAY
WORK WITH MY STAFF I DO HAVE
STAFF THERE ARE SIMILAR DESPITE
. IS THE FRONT RANGE OF
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO DIFFERENT
CITIES. AND WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
PRODUCE WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
WHAT THE OUTPUT IS GOING TO BE.
I DID LOOK AT MY OWN CITY
OBVIOUSLY- IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
INTEND TO USE THAT GRANT FUNDING
FOR. AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHEN
I LOOK AT. AND THEY GET. I THINK
AWARDED SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND. WHEN I LOOK AT- I
WULD ANTICIPATE THE CITY OF LA
WOULD BE. MUCH LARGER. A LITTLE
BIT SURPRISED AT MENDOCINO BUT
THEN WHEN I THINK ABOUT.
CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS I
GATHER. DIFFERENT REGIONS IT'S
GEOGRAPHICALLY A NEW ISSUE FOR
US TO HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
IN CLEARLY I HAVE COLLEAGUES
THAT HAVE A BETTER. WHERE THEY-
GRAPHICALLY. WHICH IS SOME MORE
RURAL COUNTIES AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE GOT LARGE CITY
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES
OAKLAND- SO I'LL BE INTERESTED
TO SEE THE OUTCOME OF THOSE
GRANTS BY THE SAME TOKEN I THEN
LOOKED AT THE EQUITY WAIVERS HI
GIVEN. DIGITAL NUMBER AND THEN
THERE WERE MORE- WAIVERS GRANTED
AND I LOOK AT YOU KNOW A HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO IN HUMBOLDT AND-
SIXTY TWO IN MID THE CNO AND-
NINETEEN IN LOS ANGELES SO I. I
WANT TO UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND
YOU CAN'T BE AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON WHEN YOU LOOK AT
DIFFERENT. AGAIN BASED ON THE
GEOGRAPHY AND THIS ISSUE IS VERY
DIFFERENT. FROM THE STANDARD
ISSUES WE LOOK AT WHEN YOU APPLY
TERMS LIKE EQUITY AND- WHAT
RESET ITSELF I WANT TO DELVE
INTO THAT A LITTLE MORE AND
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I LOOKED UP
THE DECK DEFINITION WITHIN THE
CODE AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING OF
EQUITY. AND SO- HI HI MAY FOLLOW
UP ON THAT BUT I WILL ADD TO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID. IN
TERMS OF THE COMPLEXITY AND BOY.
IT IS REALLY GREAT TO HAVE
SOMEONE THAT'S GOT THE
BACKGROUND EXPERIENCE YOU HAVE
TO DO THIS. AND TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND AND ALSO THEN TO
QUESTION HOW WE'RE DOING THIS.
AND HOW IT MEETS THOSE GOALS IN
THOSE MEASURES. SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. AND I THINK OF WILL
FOLLOW UP OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. CALLING
SAYS IT AS THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO UNFOLD- I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD UNLESS NOTHING ELSE AND
IN CASE YOU WEREN'T HERE AT THE
VERY BEGINNING WE HAVE A MEMBER
WHO'S AT THE HEALTH COMMITTEE IN
A DIFFERENT BUILDING SO- I JUST
TO PUT THAT ON THE RECORD. OF
MIDWAY THROUGH THE HEARING. ALL
I DID AT THE BEGINNING TO JUST
TO BE CLEAR BUT TO REMIND FOLKS.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO
IS MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
SOMEONE HERE YES THERE IS. IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE PEOPLE BACK. ARE
YOU TESTIFYING IN PUBLIC WHERE
WE COULD SEE THEM PLEASE- YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION OF ANY
YOU REPRESENT AND BRIEF COMMENTS
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LINDSEY
ROBINSON. FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF OUR FOUR HUNDRED PLUS
MEMBERS- WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF DCC.
DIRECTOR NICOLE ELLIOTT AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AS WE- POSSIBLY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES. OF THE
ILLICIT MARKET CONTINUES TO
GROW. DIRECTOR ELLIOTT
UNDERSTANDS THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE LEGAL LANDSCAPE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH HER TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGAL- OPERATORS ARE ABLE TO
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. WELCOME TO THE NEXT WITNESS
WELCOME BACK MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BUT REALLY YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
W. AND OUR PARTNERS AT S. C. ARE
YOU EXCUSE ME WE ARE A FULL
SUPPORT OF MISSY ELLIOTT'S
CONFIRMATION AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CC WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND DEDICATED WORK TO
ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THE LEGAL
CAMPUS MARKET WHICH ALLOWS FOR
SAFE LEGAL TESTING CANNABIS AND
SUPPORTS. A MANY CRITICAL
PROGRAMS INCLUDING CHILD CARE WE
BELIEVE THAT HURTS THAT GROUND
EXPERIENCE A COOPERATIVE SPIRIT
SERVES HER WELL IN THIS POSITION
AND CAN I ASK FOR A BETTER
CANDIDATE. WE URGE- YOUR SUPPORT
FOR CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK YOU
. HE VERY MUCH. OF THE SEEING NO
ONE ELSE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
AM GOING TO GO TO- THE
TELECONFERENCE AND I LET ME GET
A THROW UP THE NUMBER THE- TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR
ONE ONE ONE FOUR ONE. AND WITH
THAT LET ME WELCOME BACK OUR
MODERATOR. WHO TF PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MANAGER IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN
Q. OUR FIRST LINE IS LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TENANT
SENATORS. ASIAN BRAND ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION SIR I NEED YOU TO
I'M SORRY I WERE NOT HEARING YOU
VERY WELL AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN'T HEAR YOU SO PLEASE
FORGIVE ME FOR INTERRUPTING. BUT
IF YOU CAN SPEAK INTO YOUR
MOBILE DEVICE A LITTLE BIT
LOUDER. AND START OVER I
APPRECIATED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM APPROACH AND IT SENATORS.
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE KNOWN AND
WORKED WITH MICELI IT FOR MANY
YEARS. IN PREVIOUS AND CURRENT
CAPACITIES. WE KNOW SHE'S NAKED
QUALIFIED TO SERVE AS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT CAMPUS CONTROL
. IN A CRITICAL TIME FOR THE
INDUSTRY. DISTRIBUTORS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE SALLY IT TO
AFFECTED LEE LICENSE AND
REGULATE THIS INDUSTRY. YEAH
THIS IS RISHA SOCIAIS ASIAN IS
PLEASED TO OFFER ITS SUPPORT FOR
IMPROPER CONFIRMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER BRYANT APPRECIATED NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO LINE TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
YEAH IT PROVIDES- DISTRICT FIVE
MENDOCINO COUNTY. I COUNTY HAS A
LONG LEGACY OF CANNABIS
CULTIVATION. SOMETIMES ASK ME
WHAT'S THE HARDEST PROBLEM AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TODAY AND WHAT
COMES TO MIND FIRST IS NOT THE
FIRES PANDEMIC OR DROUGHT.
RATHER TRANSITIONING SMALL
CANNABIS FARMS THE LEGAL MARKET
I APPRECIATED THE DISCUSSION
EARLIER ABOUT SENIORS IMAGINE
THE THING YOU'RE TRYING TO
PERMITTED GAS STATION IN THEIR
BACKYARD. IN THE ABSTRACT THAT
OUR SMALL CANNABIS FARMS. CALL
ELLIOTT IS IN A TRUE PARTNER HE
RESPONDED TO THE COLLABORATOR
WORKS WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT
DEMONSTRATES A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEMS
BUT ALSO COMES WITH VISION AND
DRIVE TO FIND SOLUTION. YEAH MY
CONFIDENCE AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONFIRM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS- LINE TWENTY THREE
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CARLY SHALL BE
ACCOUNTANT PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CRESCO AND
MOXIE. DIGITAL EQUIPMENT
ABSTRACT OF THE DEPARTMENT
CANADA CONTROL WE REALLY ENJOYED
WORKING WITH THE CONCRETE WE
APPRECIATE HARPER HE'S
COLLECTING A PAYCHECK AND IT'S
ALL OF THE ISSUES AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER IN
ANY CAPACITY. YOUR CRITICAL HIGH
QUALITY CANNABIS. THANK YOU
CONGRATULATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
AMBER OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
U. S. E. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL IF THE W. IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE REAPPOINTMENT OF
NICOLE ELLIOTT DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
NICOLE ELLIOTT AND HER ROLE AS
DIRECTOR HAS TAKEN ON THE
GRUELING CHALLENGE OF BALANCING
REGULATE AND SUPPORTING AND
NEARLY RIGHT LEGALIZED
RECREATIONAL. AND I ALSO
BATTLING WRITING LIVES THAT
MARKET. AS A RESULT OF DIRECTOR
ELLIOTT LEADERS ON CALIFORNIA
STREAMLINED LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT CANNABIS OPERATOR.
THROUGH THE FORMATION. OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANADA CONTROL.
ONLY WORKERS NOT ONLY CANNABIS
OUR STATE FOR ANYTHING CREEK
WORKPLACE HOW BIG TRANSACTION.
U. S. STRONGLY URGES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
PARTNERS. REYES DANDER LEVINE
OKAY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WELL I AM THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- DANCE
EVEN ON BEHALF OF THE LAST
PRISONER PROJECT WE'RE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT THAT WORKS AT THE
INTERSECTION OF CANNABIS AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. EIGHTY
EIGHT THE HARMS OF CANNABIS
PROHIBITION AND THE WAR ON
DRUGS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
NOMINEE AND EARNED HER A
CONFIRMATION MICELI INSTAGRAM'S
ENDED DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
ISSUES AND BRING EDUCATION ACT
EACH OF THE SPORT. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. AGAIN HER
CONFIRMATION OF THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE TWENTY FIVE. HELLO
THE JOB BACKROOM ON BEHALF OF
THE GOOD SHELLEY ABOUT COACHELLA
VALLEY CANNABIS LIFE NETWORK AND
ALTAMONT WE WISH TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT THE COMBINATION
OF THE TWO BILLION AS DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CAMERA CONTROL. HAS CONSISTENTLY
SHOWN BOTH BEER DEDICATION TO
PROMOTING THE VIABILITY ACCOUNT
YOUR CALIFORNIA'S LIFE AND IT
DIDN'T BOTH AS WELL AS THE
OPERATIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPERIENCE
IMPORTING INDUSTRY LEADERSHIP
HAS LONG BEEN IN THE FACE AND
MOST RECENTLY GUIDED THE
INDUSTRY BOTH FOR THE IMPACT OF
CODEPENDENT MAKE AND THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE LIGHT.
AGENCIES ONE ART AND- REALLY HAS
DEMONSTRATED BUT INTERACT WITH
VERY NON IN THE STATE. IN
PROMOTE UNDER GROW THE COMMUTER
- CAL. AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE TOP WITH THE LICENSURE
AND CONTINUE TO TRANSITION INTO
A MAJORITY ALIVE OPERATORS. WE
BELIEVE IN HER LEADERSHIP AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH- THE DALLAS
CALIFORNIA AT THE EXAMPLE OF
RESPONSIBLE LEGALIZATION THANK%
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE TWENTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON I DON'T PUT
ON THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS AMBER
TURNER GOING AND I'M A DETECTIVE
WITH THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT OF SPEAKING BEFORE%
YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF NICOLE ELLIOTT
IS A DIRECTOR. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL I
KNOW THAT CANNABIS REGULATION
HASN'T BEEN EASY FOR NICOLE NOR
HER PREDECESSORS HOWEVER THE
CALL IS BEEN AT THE HELM I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE SEC'S ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION SPECIFICALLY THE LOS
ANGELES UNIT FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS WE WORKED TOGETHER ON
NUMEROUS UNLICENSED COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS CASES WE'VEDEVELOPED A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP WITH WHICH
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. SOME OF
OUR SUCCESSFUL COLLABORATION
INVOLVED WORKING. HELLO IS A NEW
TECH. TO COMBAT ILLEGAL
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS TRADE. AND
ASSISTING AND SUPPORTING THE
LEGAL CANNABIS STAKEHOLDERS. I
SEE IN THE UNIT GROW IN SIZE AND
HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF SEEING
THEM CONDUCT THOROUGH AND
SUCCESSFUL INVESTIGATIONS. UNIT
HAS GREAT MORALE ESPRIT DE CORPS
AND IS VERY PROFESSIONAL THAT'S
NOT JUST A REFLECTION. OF ITS
INVESTIGATORS IN THE WORK ETHIC
BUT A REFLECTION OF THEIR
IMMEDIATE DETECTIVE SERGEANTS.
COMMANDERS THE CHIEF BILL JONES
AND IS A TESTAMENT TO THE VISION
AND LEADERSHIP OF NICKEL IT. I
WISH YOU CONTINUED SUCCESS AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. BUYING TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS STRONG KELLY
RIGHT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SILICON VALLEY CANNABIS ALLIANCE
WITH MEMBERS AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
ALAMEDA COUNTIES- GOVERNMENT IS
SOMETIMES DIFFICULT ACCESS.
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT IS REALLY
VERY MEANINGFUL FOR EVERYONE IN
THE STATE ESPECIALLY BUSINESS
OWNERS RECORD LEN PROVIDE OUR
MEMBERS WITH ACCESS THE
GOVERNMENT. INVOICE OUR OPINIONS
AND ACQUISITIONS. HEY GET
MEDICAL. ANKLE FEEDBACK AND AT
IS REALLY EVERYTHING I MEAN WE
TALK ABOUT CANADA'S HERE TO TALK
ABOUT ACCESS AND ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S ONE THING THAT
NICHOLAS HAS CONSISTENTLY DONE
FOR US SO. WE CAN VALLEY CAMPUS
ALLIANCE WOULD STRONGLY SUPPORT
HI NICOLE ELLIOTT COUNTERACT ARE
OF THE DIVISION THIS CALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. I AM FOURTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ALAN BARCELONA
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION
MARTINEZ SEVEN. IT IS SEVEN
REPRESENTS THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN THAT
DIVISION AND THEY STRONGLY. PORT
DIRECTOR ELLIOTT AND SO DO I
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE THIRTEEN. THANK
YOU IRAQ IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STEVEN MAIL ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION AND WE
RISE AND- CURRENT TWELVE
DIRECTOR ELLIOTT FOR THE DCC-
SHE'LL THE GREAT LEADER DURING
THIS TUMULTUOUS TIME THAT THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY FINDS HERSELF
IN. OUR CELL DAMAGE SHE HAD THE
EXPERTISE AND KNOWLEDGE IN
CANNABIS POLICY TO LEAVE DURING
THE- WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF HER. RECONFIRMATION
YEAH ON BEHALF OF THE LBC LBC A
AND ALSO THE ORANGE COUNTY
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WE LIVE IN
FAVOR OF. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE. THIRTY
FOUR. YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS AMY JOHN CAN
ON BEHALF OF CLASS AS PART BOTH
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANY BASED IN SONOMA COUNTY
AND WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH NICOLE ELLIOTT OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND AS THE
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO INDOOR
PICNIC AGAIN CHALLENGES WE
BELIEVE WE NEED A STRONG LEADER
AT THE TV EASY THE CALL IS THAT
LEADER. ARE CURRENTLY SUFFERING
FROM A LACK AND A LACK OF RETAIL
ACCESS AND BURDENSOME
REGULATIONS THIS IS PROFOUNDLY
AFFECTING OUR BUSINESS SAYS
DIRECTOR ELLIOTT UNDERSTANDS.
THE DIFFICULTIES WE FACE. ARIENS
THE GROW PAIN BUT ARE IN. AND AS
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATIVELY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH US TO FIND
SOLUTIONS FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATION STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE NET MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS TRACY
STEVENS. FROM GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF BODY AND
MIND A MULTISTATE CANNABIS
LICENSEE WE HAD THE PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH MICELI AT OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. AND WE FIND HER
TO BE COMPLETELY ACCESSIBLE AND
WILLING TO LISTEN TO ALL OF THE
INDUSTRY CONCERT. FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT HER NOMINATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS GERRY
KYLO THE PRESIDENT UNITED CAME
AS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CAN DEFINITELY
COMPETE ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO CANNABIS RETAILERS
ALIGN- WITH OVER THE YEARS- IT'S
L. IT HAS BEEN AN AMAZING. TOOL
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE CAMERA TO
THE STREET- WE WORK WITH HER.
FROM HER POSITION IN SAN
FRANCISCO. REGULATOR INTO THE
LIAISE- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FOR CANADA NOW TO THE
DIRECTORSHIP OF THE PARK ON THE
CAMPUS CONTROL I FEEL LIKE THERE
IS NO ONE MORE QUALIFIED
CURRENTLY UNDERSTAND THE LOCAL
STATE AND ISSUES THAT ARE GOING
TO COME BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- DENTICLE
ELLIOTT. AND HER ACCESSIBILITY
AND HER KNOWLEDGE OF ALL OF
THESE ASPECTS MADE A REALLY
PLEASURE TO DEAL WITH HER OVER
THE YEARS. HE TREATS US LIKE
FAMILY MEMBERS BECAUSE SHE
TREATED HIM WITH INDUSTRY LIKE
THE FAMILY SHE RAIN SO I REALLY
. THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE HER
MOVE TO THE DIRECTOR AND-
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
CANNOT CONTROL AND- STRONGLY.
REJECTING PROVE HER TO BE
NOMINATED AND BROUGHT INTO THE
DEPARTMENT CAPITAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
. WELL I AM THIRTY NINE. HELLO
THIS IS MISTER VERA WITH BOTH
WORK WITH THE L. A. AND I'M LIKE
SUPPORT OF NICOLE LEN. IT'S BEEN
GREAT AND ADVOCATE AND NOT
CREATE OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU COLONEL
FOR THE LINE FROM SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATE WILL PROBABLY BE BACK
WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT. SO
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO
ONE ARE. MISTER MODERATOR WERE
COMING BACK TO YOU. TO SEE IF
YOU CAN TEAR UP THE FOLKS WHO
ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS. NOMINEE I MEAN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A LITTLE WHILE. WITH THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES LET ME BRING THIS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM CHAIR I WOULD MOVE
THE CONFIRMATION OF NACOLEIA
THIS DIRECTOR. THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH KAMLAGER I
AM LONGER I LAYERED AYE AYE
BATES ALL RIGHT EIGHT I ACTON
FIVE. ANQING IT'S ON CALL
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE ONE MEMBER
TO COME BACK FROM HEALTH
COMMITTEE BUT I WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS THIS WILL MOVE
TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MICELI. THANK
YOU SENATORS ABSOLUTELY AND WITH
GREAT RESPECT TO THE LAST
APPOINTEE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
FIVE MINUTES- AND WE WILL BE
PROMPTLY BACK WITH YOU AND READY
TO GO AND WE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE SO A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK. COLLEAGUES AND THE
CLOCK IS TICKING.
DOLLAR TECHNOLOGY IS WORKING
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN LET ME-
WELCOME- OUR NEXT APPOINTEE ITEM
ONE SEE UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR%
AND THAT WOULD BE THE
APPOINTMENT OF DENNIS V. ALFIERI
AND I HOPE I SAID YOUR NAME
RIGHT. FIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING BOARD AND I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE- THIS AFTERNOON AND
WITH THAT I WOULD IN THANK YOU
TO. INTRODUCE YOURSELF RECOGNIZE
THANK ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DO YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK
YOU SENATOR ACTIONS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF AT THE
RULES COMMITTEE- BY THE WAY I
DIDN'T MIND WAITING BECAUSE I
ENJOYED EVERY MINUTE OF IT. MORE
ABOUT ARE YOU DRINKING.
APOCALYPTIC I'M SORRY AND
CANNABIS STATE'S. ALL FIRST LET
ME THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FERRARI
WARNING TO THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD- APPRECIATED VERY
MUCH. LONG FARMS OF FRIEND OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BOB YES ON A
PLEASURE TO SERVE ON THE BOARD.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF GREAT WORK
AND I AM SEEKING RE APPOINTMENT
AND CONFIRMATION BECAUSE THAT
WORK IS NOT FINISHED. I'VE HAD A
LONG STANDING PASSION FOR THE
SPORT. AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
PLEASING TO BE A PART OF WHAT
THE SPORT. IS DOWN TO REFORM AND
TRULY BETTER THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF THE HORSE. AND ALL
THOSE WHO BENEFIT ECONOMICALLY
FROM THE HORSERACING INDUSTRY.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS I'VE
WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS. ON THE
BOARD TO SUCCESSFULLY PASS OVER
THIRTY REGULATIONS ENHANCING
PROTECTIONS. FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF HORSES AND RIDERS.
RESULTING IN AN OVERALL 50%
DECLINE IN EQUINE FATALITIES. MY
GOALS OF CONFIRMED FOR A NEW
TERM ON THE BOARD IS TO BUILD
OUR SUCCESSFUL WORK WITH RESPECT
TO ANIMAL WELFARE AND HORSE AND
RIDER SAFETY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR CONVERSATION TODAY. YOU
SO MUCH- LET ME ASK MADAM VICE
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO START.
THANK YOU AND I THINK YOU MISTER
FEAR YOU ARE FOR YOUR SERVICE I
SUPPORTED YOU ARE IN OUR LAST
INTERVIEW IN PRE PANDEMIC. I'VE
BEEN VERY PLEASED WITH THE
MANNER IN WHICH YOU HAVE
CONDUCTED- YOURSELF ON THE BOARD
AND WITH VERY VERY DIFFICULT
ISSUES AND A NUMBER OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD I CERTAINLY WITH A
BALANCED VIEW THAT. YOU WERE
ABLE TO PUT FORTH SO YOU'LL HAVE
MY SUPPORT I JUST HAVE ONE-
QUESTION CONCERNED ENOUGH ABOUT
THE SPORTS WERE FORCED WAY
DURING INITIATIVE. ARM YOUR
COMMENT- OF GREAT CONCERN AND
INTEREST TO THE BOARD GIVEN THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES AS
PROPOSED IN I JUST LIKE TO HEAR
A LITTLE MORE. OFTEN YOU ON THAT
ISSUE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
SITTING THERE AND YOU UNDERSTAND
THOSE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES
THAT YOU CAN SHARE THAT WITH US
AS WE GO FORWARD. THAT WILL BE
COMING ON A BIG ISSUE IN THAT
YEAH YOU KNOW ABOUT THE COMING
MONTHS. FOR THE LORD HAS YET TO
TAKE A POSITION ON FOR
INITIATIVES. ARE FILED BY THE-
WITH THE AG TO DATE BUT
RECOGNIZES THE POTENTIAL. FOR
SPORTS WAGERING WILL IT WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT AND REQUIRES. OUR
ALL OF OUR ATTENTION- I THINK
THE ONLY. ONE THAT HAS BEEN
APPROVED FOR THE BALLOT EMBRACE
BALLOT- IS A CALIFORNIA SPORTS
AGERING REGULATION. I'M LAST
UNLAWFUL GAMBLING GAMBLING
ENFORCEMENT ACT- SO GONNA ACT.
WELL I AM SUPPORTIVE OF IT- ARE
YOU THINK YEAH IT MEANS A LOT TO
THE SPORT AS WELL AS OTHER
SPORTS BRINGS I THINK MORE
INCOME TWO OF THE STATE- IN IN
DIFFERENT WAYS OFTEN TAXES- AND
SO- THIS LAN- IF AUTHORIZED-
WILL- I THINK IT'LL BE PROBABLY
ONLY ONE OF FOUR INITIATIVES
LIKELY TO BE THE ONLY ONE THAT
WILL BE. ON THE NOVEMBER EIGHTH.
SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE SO. TO EARLY
TO TELL THERE ARE PROS AND CONS
. BECAUSE IT IS THE NEGATIVES TO
WORK AS WE FURTHER ALONG WILL BE
ABLE TO LOOK INTO IT FURTHER AND
UNDERSTAND. AND THIS FUTURE BE
WILL DEFINITELY TAKE A POSITION
. THANK YOU FOR THAT WILL BE
LOOKING OUT CERTAINLY I WILL BE
LOOKING OUT TO HERE ON THE
BOARDS OF REVIEW OF THAT AND
CERTAINLY THE DISCUSSION OF THE
PROS AND CONS IT SEEMS. MOST OF
THE INFORMATION I RECEIVED IS
THAT A REAL CONCERNED ABOUT.
IMPACTING FROM THE EXISTING-
AREAS AND ALSO OF POTENTIAL WITH
WHEN WE HAVE THE PROBLEM WITH-
YOU KNOW GAMBLING ADDICTION AND
IF THAT IS GOING TO INCREASE
THAT AND ESPECIALLY AMONGST OUR
YOUTH. ARE SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS I'LL BE HOPING TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT FROM YOUR BOARD
ISSUE- DISCUSSING THOSE PROS AND
CONS AND THE CONSEQUENCES. BUT
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
ESPECIALLY DURING THAT VERY
DIFFICULT TIME WITH THE SAFETY
ISSUES. AND OF THE MEASURE THE
WAY YOU APPROACH THAT THE
BALANCED WAY YOU APPROACH THAT I
TRULY APPRECIATED IT SO. YOU
WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT- OF YOUR
CONFIRMATION THAT WE AND WE GET
TO THE VOTE THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU START. THANK YOU. US
SENATOR KERR MARKER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. THE NEXT SURE THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM. UM SO THANK YOU
MR AFARIA I APOLOGIZE THAT WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO FIND TIME- THIS
WEEK TO. MEET BUT I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READ. SOME OF
YOUR STATEMENTS IN YOUR BIO AND-
YOU LIKE I HAVE AND- SO I. FROM
DECEMBER ONE QUESTION AND A
COMMENT BUT THE QUESTION IS
THAT- YOU KNOW THE ARGUMENT IS
THAT GOOD HORSES ARE NOT COMING
TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE PURSES
ARE NOT COMPETITIVE ENOUGH TO
LURE THEM AND BECAUSE WE'RE
KILLING THEM- YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH I KNOW YOU SAID THERE'S
BEEN A FIFTY PERCENT. DECLINE IN
A CRIME- FATALITIES WE DID HAVE
A KENTUCKY DERBY WINNER- DIæN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO I WANT TO
KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT IN IN
IN WHAT WE DO ABOUT THIS. WELL
ACTUALLY JUST TODAY AT THE
JOCKEY CLUB- RELEASED A
STATEMENT- AND TALKED ABOUT.
EQUINE FATALITY THROUGH- THE
EQUINE INJURY DATABASE- IT WAS
RELEASED ON TODAY AND IT'S
SAYING THAT THE INDUSTRY
SWEEPING EFFORT TO IMPROVE
RACING SAFETY ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS CONTINUES TO PAY
DIVIDENDS. CALIFORNIA IS BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE WE'VE WE'RE
WE'RE DOING SO WELL HERE- WITH
AS I SAID R. FIFTY PERCENT- IF
YOU WISH YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE ALL THE WAY DOWN. INTO
WHERE WE USED TO PRACTICALITIES-
I AM PROUD TO SAY- THIS REPORT
IS PASSED AS I SAID THIRTY
REGULATIONS ENHANCING
PROTECTIONS. OVERALL WORK 50%
DECLINE IN EQUINE FATALITIES.
FURTHER DECREASING ANOTHER 40%
JUST SINCE JANUARY ONE-
REGULATORY CHANGES THAT INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE LIMITATION ON JOINT
INJECTIONS OF BEFORE WORKOUTS
AND RACES WE MONITOR THIS
CONSTANTLY DAILY LIMITATIONS ON
THE USE OF RIDING CROPS DURING
RACE- WE LEAD WE LEAD THE NATION
IN A MAIL ORDER STATES ARE
FOLLOWING THROUGH- REQUIREMENTS
THE FACT. EXAMINATIONS BEFORE
WORKOUTS AND REYES. AND LASTLY
WE HAVE WE CREATED A REVIEW
PANEL- REGARDING A FROM THE
FITNESS FROM TRAINING THE DAILY
REYES AND THEN THERE'S A REVIEW
PANEL TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE FIT ENOUGH TO RACE- YOUR
QUESTION IS THERE THERE SEEM TO
BE SOME OF THAT A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- OF COURSE OWNERS WERE WERE
TAKING THEIR HORSES ELSEWHERE-
BECAUSE- THANKS THANK RARE RACES
IN GENERAL. WE'RE NOT PAYING
ENOUGH YOU KNOW NOT GETTING
ENOUGH OF THEIR ATTENTION ON
THEIR INTERESTS THAT'S STRANGE-
THESE STAKEHOLDERS DIFFERENT
RACING FACILITIES HAVE RAISED
THEIR STAKES OF THEIR RACE
RACING UP PERSONS- IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THIS LIST LAST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THERE WERE
MUCH HIGHER THAN TWENTY TWENTY
AND PREVIOUS. AND SO WE DID SEE
THAT MOMENT MUCH OF AN ACCENT-
FROM- YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE ONLY THREE
OR FOUR THREE DAYS OF RACING OUT
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WAS BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC- SOLD THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THOSE. THOSE RACES ARE
BEING FILLED- BUT THERE ARE
THERE'S NOT AS DAYS. WHEN I UP
YOURS GOING TO RE. THEY BE READY
CERTIFIED A WEEK. NOT NOW SO. DO
YOU THINK REALLY YOUR- ORDER
KINDA NOT REALLY DO YOU THINK
WE'RE GETTING- DO YOU THINK
WE'RE GETTING GOOD HORSES. YES
YES. WE'RE GETTING GOOD HORSES
ALL OF THE WORST. WORST MILLION
THREE THREE HORSES JUST WANT TO
DO BODY THIS LAST WEEKEND. ONE
THANK YOU IN FIRST AND SECOND-
CALIFORNIA BRED- CALIFORNIA
HORSES. NOT BRED. KENTUCKY BRED
THE CALIFORNIA HORSES ONE. A
TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR RAISED-
THE NEW BIKE WORLD CLASS SO WE
HAVE HORSES COMING THAT ARE
HEARING CALIFORNIA. THAT ARE
RACING AND WE HAVE QUITE A FEW.
MAJOR RAISE STAKES RACE. AFTER
OUR FACILITIES. THE BILL MAHER
SAMUDA BOWLING GATE A LAWSUIT. I
DON'T SEE AS MUCH OF A DECLINE
IN THAT RIGHT NOW. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU I AM.
SO LIKE YOU I ALSO SORT OF GREW
UP AROUND THIS INDUSTRY- AND
SPENT TIME AT SANTA ANITA AND
HOLLYWOOD PARK IN DELAMAR I'M UP
AND DOWN AND I WILL SAY THAT
I'VE SORT OF SEEN IT CHANGE- IN
THE QUALITY. OF- OF HORSES AND
IN IN THE PURSES AND THERE'S
BEEN A SHIFT TO KIND OF TAKE
THINGS AS YOU MENTIONED OUT OF
THE COUNTRY. AND CERTAINLY BACK
TO THE EAST- AND IF THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN INDUSTRY THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT- YOU KNOW. I
DO THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT I HOPE THAT YOUR BOARD WILL.
CONTINUE TO BE INTERESTED IN-
HOW WE ARE SUPPORTING. JOCKEYS
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S
A PREVALENCE OF- SUBSTANCE USE
AND ABUSE. ARE BASED ON THE
PRESSURES AND THE STRESS OF THE
JOB- IN THE WEIGHT MANAGEMENT
THAT THEY HAVE TO. SORT OF
MONITOR- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR MEETING REQUIREMENTS TO
REYES. AND THEN THE FACT THAT
REVENUES HAVE GONE DOWN WITH
RACETRACKS ACROSS THE STATE.
WHICH IS REALLY IMPACTED-
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
GENERATIONS. OF FAMILIES WHO
HAD. LIVELIHOODS BECAUSE OF THIS
INDUSTRY WHERE THEY WORK THEY'VE
LIVED- YOU KNOW AFTER TRACK.
CLOSE TO IT WORKING WITH HORSES-
AND NOT WANTING TO. DECIMATE
THAT INDUSTRY SO I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT- YOU ALL CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE I
THINK THEY WILL BE PREVALENT-
FOR HOW THIS INDUSTRY IS ABLE TO
SUSTAIN IN THIS STATE. AND HOW
WE ARE ABLE TO ATTRACT- BACK-
COMPETITIVE HORSES WHO MAY BE
FROM CALIFORNIA OR WHO HATE MAY
NOT BUT THE GOAL IS TO HAVE AN
EXPERIENCE THAT IS BOTH SAFE FOR
THE OWNERS. AND OBVIOUSLY THE
HORSES AS WELL AS FOR THE FOLKS
THAT ARE STILL INTERESTED- IN-
PARTICIPATING AND ATTENDING
THESE PARTICULAR EVENTS- SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOU TODAY BUT
I JUST NEEDED TO PUT ON THE
RECORD MY CONTINUED CONCERNS-
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MY HOPE
THAT YOU ALL WILL. CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP DELVE INTO THESE ISSUES
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FROM MISTER FARIA APPRECIATE-
YOUR SERVICE IN YOUR APPEARING
HERE TODAY I WANNA ASK SENATOR
CALM WATERS WHO ARE PART OF A
QUESTION A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
AND THAT IS THAT THE F. CLOSE
ALAMEDA BECAUSE THERE WAS A
SPIKE IN FATALITIES IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN THE BOARD
DECIDED TO HAVE A- A PLAN TO
REDUCE THAT. M. O. THERE WAS A
SIX MONTH PERMITTED IT WAS
REVERSED IN IT AND GOT TO A YEAR
AND THEN GOLDEN GATE FIELDS
RACETRACKS ON INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHERE THERE'S A TOTAL
OF TWENTY SEVEN DEATHS FROM
MULTIPLE CAUSES AND THERE WAS A
DEBATE ON THE BOARD IT'S WITH
FORTY THREE AGAIN WITH GOLDEN
GATE FIELDS RECEIVING SIX MONTHS
. R. INSTEAD OF FOUR PEOPLE
VOTED FOR THAT AND THREE VOTED.
R. FOR THREE MONTHS IN. A ARE
YOU CITED THE FACT THAT THEIR
STATISTICS SHOWING THERE'S A
GREAT APPROVAL BUT IF THERE WAS
TWENTY SEVEN DEATHS AT. AT
GOLDEN GATE FIELDS LAST YEAR
IT'S TOO SHORT TO DECIDE WHETHER
OVER TIME THERE'S A DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT SO. HOW DO YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS WHAT'S ON THE BOARD
AND- WHY YOU THINK WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS REALLY. DOING THE RIGHT
INTERVAL FOR REPORTS TO GET ON
TOP OF THIS. WELL FIRST LET ME
SAY I DIDN'T VOTE TO SUPPORT
THANKS MONTHS LICENSE- THIS NEED
THIRTEEN THIRTY TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY- AND SHORT TERM
LICENSES. THREE MONTHS IS WHAT
THE PROPOSAL WAS DISTRUSTFUL
POSITIVE LOCAL AND STATEWIDE
ECONOMIC IMPACT GENERATED FROM
RAISED MEATS. APPROXIMATELY A
THOUSAND WORKERS EACH RACING
FACILITY. MANY OF WHICH ARE
AFFORDED HOUSING ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO AN IMMEDIATE
TERMINATION OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT
. REGULATIONS ALL OUTLAWS WE
HAVE THE ABILITY REGULATORY
ABILITY TO SUSPEND RACING AND
TRAINING AT A TRACK AT ANY TIME
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT SAFETY
ISSUES- AND WE CONTINUE TO
EXERCISE THAT DISCRETION AS WE
MONITOR RACING ACTIVITY- I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT. WHICH WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER FELLOW HORSES
IF THEIR OWNERS AND TRAINERS
FEEL THERE'S ONLY THREE MONTHS
LICENSE THEY WON'T SPEND THE
MONEY TO TRANSFER THEM HERE
TRANSPORT THEM WHAT THE MOCK. UP
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A PERIOD OF
TIME OPERATE THEIR BUSINESS- AND
THEY WILL MOVE OUT OF STATE. SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASON WHY I
DIDN'T FEEL THAT THREE MONTHS
LICENSE- WE CAN WE CAN WE SEE A
SPIKE IN. EQUINE DASSLER. WE CAN
WE CAN SHUT IT DOWN AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING I BROUGHT THAT
UP IN OUR IN OUR LAST MEETING.
THAT WE SHOULD WILL MONITOR IT
DAILY WHICH IS WHAT THE FUTURITY
STAFF IS DOING AND STORAGE AND
WORK AND WE SEE A SPIKE. WE CAN
WE ALL TAKE MERGENCY ACTION AND
WE WILL WE WILL WE WILL SUSPEND
RACING. AND WE WILL LOOK INTO
THE MATTER WHICH BERMAN. FIND
OUT WHY THEY'RE SUCH AS BY WHAT
WE'RE DOING THAT DAILY ANYWAY MY
STOCKTON LOS ALAMEDA IS. STILL
HAPPENING HOLDEN GATE- BUT WE
FELT THAT THEY DIDN'T TURN
AROUND- EVAN WAS ADEQUATE- THE
WHAT WE SAW. OF HER TURN MATALAN
. ARE QUICKLY- BUT NO FIRE. WELL
IT'S AN IN IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
BALANCE BECAUSE AT SOME POINT
AND THERE'S TO JOBS AND IF
THERE'S A SPIKE IN HORSES DEATHS
. IN SOME WAYS THAT'S WHAT IT
GETS WEIGHED AGAINST WHAT THE
REAL ISSUE SHOULD BE. WHY ARE SO
MANY HORSES DYING AND IS THERE A
WAY TO GET ON TOP OF IT AND IF
THE GOLDEN GATE FIELDS IS TWENTY
SEVEN DEATHS LAST YEAR. R. IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S HARD TO
MAKE A DEFINITIVE STATEMENT
THEY'RE GETTING ON TOP OF IT FOR
ONLY TWO MONTHS INTO THIS YEAR
MAYBE THERE'S NO DEATHS AT THE
FIRST TWO MONTHS. AND THAT COMES
TO THE CONCLUSION BUT- I THINK
WE AT THE RULES COMMITTEE TO THE
CONFIRMATIONS AND THIS TURNS
INTO AN OVERSIGHT PROCESS AND
I'M- JUST HOPING THAT. YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE A
GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THOSE DEATHS
AND THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HOPE THE BOARD WILL ACT ON.
IT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND- IF
IN FACT. THE BOARD IS WILLING TO
REALLY TAKE STRONG ACTION
BECAUSE THERE'S A SPIKE IN
DEATHS OVER THE SHORT TERM.
THAT'S A STRONG STATEMENT AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT I JUST HEARD
YOU SAY BUT- THE A SHORTAGE YOU
CAN MAKE THE RENEWALS. WHEN
THERE'S SUCH A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN. IN A CLIENT DEBTS IS SORT OF
A STATEMENT THAT YOU WILL BE
LOOKING AND THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
THAT RATHER THAN FEELING THAT.
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO BE GIVEN A
PASS UNTIL THERE IS ANOTHER
SPIKE SO. I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS
EXCHANGE SO YOU UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN AND- AND YOU ACTED AS
BEST AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE. ABSOLUTELY FOUNDER
WE CAN WE CAN TRAIN YOU SEE
CHARLIE CONTINUES TO CLOSELY
MONITOR. AND SCRUTINIZE
ACTIVITIES AT THESE RACE TRACKS-
AND WE WILL TAKE APPROPRIATE
ACTION. THERE'S NO THERE'S NOT A
DAY GOES BY THAT WE ARE ALL OVER
. ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID WHEN
I FIRST GOT ON THIS BOARD WAS IT
WILL NOT BE BUSINESS AS USUAL
IT'S NOT LIKE THE OLD DAYS. AND
SINCE THEN WE'VE ENACTED THIRTY
REGULATIONS. M. EQUINE DEATHS
ARE WAY DOWN. AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
PROUD OF THAT NO WE DON'T. WE
DON'T I DON'T LIKE TO SEE ONE
HORSE. NO ONE ON THIS BOARD AND-
BUT IT YEAH- YOU HAVE THESE
ISSUES WELL I THINK THERE'S JUST
ONE PLACE WHERE MAYBE WE'RE
TALKING OVER PASSED EACH OTHER
BECAUSE MAYBE IT LOS ONLY TO
STARE DOWN BUT AT GOLDEN GATE
FIELDS THEY WEREN'T SO DOWN AND
THAT IS REALLY RECENT AND SO ARE
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS AND IT
CAME UP IN AN EARLIER HEARING
TODAY. THIRTY REGULATIONS DON'T
MEAN ANYTHING. UNLESS THERE'S AN
ABSOLUTE CHANGE IN WHAT THE
OUTCOME IS SAID THAT'S WHAT I
THINK WE WOULD BE. CONCERNED
ABOUT I APPRECIATE WHEN I WAS
THERE DOWN WE WERE DOWN FALL
PREVIOUS YEAR AFTER LOS ALAMOS.
AND SO WELL THAT'S WHAT I MEANT
WHEN I SAID THEY WILL WORK ON
SOME WAYS IT'S- I'M NOT.
NECESSARILY SURE THAT'S THE
THRESHOLD YOU ALWAYS WANT TO
MEASURE AGAINST IT. I AGREE OKAY
ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR THE EXTRA
TRIP CHRISTIAN. INTERLAYER THANK
YOU ARE YOU PREPARED I WANT I
WANT TO GIVE US SENATOR GROVE
ENOUGH TIME TO CATCH HER BREATH
COMING FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
IN A DIFFERENT BUILDING SO.
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME AND CATCH MY
BREATH AND LET SENATOR LAYERED
FINISH. I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND WE HAVE TO HAVE I
WAS MY A TWELVE YEAR OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER WHO FOLLOWS
RESOURCING. AND FANATICALLY SHE
EVEN DID A REPORT IN A TIMELINE
ON BOB BAFFERT IN MEDINA SPIRIT.
I WHICH HE MADE ALL OF US VERY
WELL EDUCATED ON- BEEN SINCE I'M
NOT HER- YOU GET TWO QUESTIONS-
SO THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
THESE. SO HOW DO YOU BALANCE
ECHOING SAFETY ON THE TRACK
OPERATIONS WHEN CONSIDERING
WHETHER TO GRANT LICENSES ON
TRACKS. AND THAT'S MY QUESTION I
DO APOLOGIZE IF THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN ASKED BECAUSE I WAS IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. YOU NEED TO
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LICENSE THROUGH A REGULAR
TRAINER YES SIR. HOW DO YOU
BALANCE THE OPERATIONS OF GIVING
WHEN CONSIDERING THOSE LICENSES
AT WHAT'S THE PROCESS TO GO
THROUGH THAT AND D. IS THEIR
BACKGROUNDS ARE REGULATORY
PROCESSES WHERE YOU ADD DO
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON THE
INDIVIDUALS THE TRAINERS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. ABSOLUTELY
SIGNIFICANT BACKGROUND CHECKS.
OUT YOUR BROUGHT UP. THE TRAINER
BOB BAFFERT PAUL PAUL FRANK
FRANK- YOU KNOW HE IS HAVING
ISSUES OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING BACK- BUT-
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON EVEN MORE SCREWED THAN
SINCE I'VE BEEN ON THE SPORT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS- THAT I AM
ENJOYING TO SEE IS THE WITH THE
CURRENT LICENSED TRAINERS WE'RE
PUSHING AND PUSHING AND DOING
MOR CONTINUING EDUCATION. SO
NOT ONLY WERE THEY WHEN THEY
WERE LICENSED THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN EDUCATION THINGS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BROADEN THAT
EDUCATION- EACH EACH YEAR EACH
SEASON- ALL THESE TRIPS ARE.
LICENSED TRAINERS IN THE STATE-
AND WE'VE GOT MORE EDUCATION
ACTUALLY FOR OWNERS AS WELL
FORCE OWNERS. BUT- ACTUALLY I'M
NOT SURE OF YOUR ASKING ME A BOB
OR JUST IN. NO SIR I WAS JUST
MAKING A COMMENT THAT IF MY
TWELVE YEAR OLD GRANDDAUGHTER
WAS HERE SHE WOULD BE ASKING
YOU. ABOUT BOB. AN OF. THERE ARE
THERE ARE QUITE A BIT OF THREE
MAKE INCLUDING THEIR ASSISTANT
TRAINERS AND- BACKTRACKS
ABSOLUTELY AND THE LAST QUESTION
I HAVE IS THERE'S A LOT OF
DEBATE AND CONTROVERSY GOING ON
ABOUT SPORTS AND WE TRINA
BETTING FEDERAL OUT OF
HORSERACING TRACKS TO OFFER SUCH
BETTING BETTING AND WHAT
OVERSIGHT ROLE IF ANY DO YOU
THINK THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD SHOULD HAVE- AT OF
ANY SPORTS BETTING ACTIVITY.
WELL WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THAT
EARLIER- I USED YOU KNOW WORD
IT'S TOO EARLY TO TELL. THE PROS
AND CONS WE DON'T KNOW ALL OF
THE USERS YEAH WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THESE LARGEST LATIUM- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IT'LL BE ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT. A TO SEE IF
THAT WILL EVEN BE APPROVED OR
NOT- AND THEN WE'LL GO FROM
THERE THANKS WE HAVE NOT TAKEN
THE CRB HAS NOT TAKEN A POSITION
ON. BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T KNOW
ALL THE FACTS. THERE WILL
DEFINITELY WE WILL DEFINITELY BE
ALL. YEAH YOU THAT YOUR PLAYER%
IN IT LIKE WHAT WOULD THINK YOUR
ROLE WOULD BE. WELL I I'M SURE
THERE WILL BE BECAUSE THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT. WHERE YOU BRING
AB BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITIES
ALSO AND SO. WE WILL BE WE WILL
WE'RE GRANTING LICENSES BREKKEN
MORE FACILITIES AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
YOU KNOW HAVING THIS- WAGERING
AS WELL AS SONG OFFLINE ONLINE-
THE LITTLE PEOPLE THOUGHT VERY
MUCH SO WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY
INVOLVED. BUT IT'S JUST TOO
EARLY TO TELL I AM NOT AN EXPERT
AS TO WHAT YOU KNOW THESE ISSUES
WILL BE BOTH PROS AND CONS AND
WHAT THE REGULATION RIGHT
REGULATORY STOCK CLARK- I SEE
THE BENEFIT THOUGH I PERSONALLY
FEEL. IT'LL WHAT IS MORE FORCING
THEM TO HANDLE THIS BET ON
HORSES AT OUR FACILITIES IN THE
STATE IS LARGE OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE. AND SO THERE'S. ALREADY
OUT THROUGH WAGERING- DIFFERENT
FACILITY- ALL ONLINE. YEAH YOU
CAN BET ON YOUR PHONE ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD- AND WE BENEFIT
FROM WE DO GET A PIECE OF THAT
ANIMAL. SO THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING
THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROWTH- THANK YOU. AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH I ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
FOR AWHILE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE I REMEMBER PREVIOUS- OUR
CONFIRMATIONS AND- UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT BOTH AT THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR- AND
I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND AND SAY I
DO THINK IT IS TRUE THAT THE
REFORMS ADOPTED BY THE BOARD
HAVE. HAD SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS I FOLLOW THIS I
REPRESENT ARE A PART OF SAN
DIEGO THAT DEL MAR AND THAT
HISTORY AND THAT LEGACY SO THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ON
LIMITING THE USE OF RIDING CROP.
CHANGES TO THE DESIGN-
INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF COURSE
COURSES FITNESS BEFORE THE RACES
RESTRICTIONS ALL MEDICATIONS.
REVIEW OF VETERINARY RECORDS ALL
THOSE THINGS YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE POOR SOME POOR POST MORTEM.
REVIEW OF THE FATALITIES- ARE
ALL TOOLS THAT WERE NEEDED TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS. ARE BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN IT FLUCTUATE YEAR BY YEAR
END AND ALSO. OF THE SCANNERS IN
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE- NOT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
UNFORTUNATELY I KNOW WE'RE
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS A POSSIBILITY SO I THINK IT
HAS WORKED TO MAKE. CALIFORNIA A
LEADER WHICH HAS HAD SOME
PROBABLY ECONOMIC IMPACTS ON-
THE PEOPLE WHO BRING THEIR
HORSES HERE TO RACE I THINK OUR
OUR STANDARDS ARE HIGHER. NEVER
THE LESS I THINK THERE'S MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WITH IT YOU'RE
WELL AWARE OF BECAUSE- I WHO
STILL THINK. AND THAT IS A BIG
EXTREME. BACK TO- SENATOR
GLAZERS COMMENT ABOUT LOSS
ALAMEDA DOES I REMEMBER WHEN WE
SAW OF SPIKE IT WASN'T A
SIGNIFICANT SPIKE BUT ANY COURSE
DEATH ISSUE SAID IS SOMETHING
TO. BE CONCERNED ABOUT BUT I
REMEMBER- AFTER A FEW IN SAN
DIEGO IN DEL MAR I WENT OUT AND
DID A TOUR THE TRACK AND TALK TO
FOLKS AND LOOKED AT. EVERYTHING
THAT WENT INTO PREPARING A TRACK
FOR- NOT ONLY FOR RACING DAY BUT
FOR- THE PRACTICE AND THE
TRAINING. DO YOU- DID YOU
NOTICE- WERE YOU ABLE ON THE
BOARD WHEN THAT WHEN THE BOARD
OVERTURNED ITS ORIGINAL. ODD
DECISION ON THE ONE YEAR
LICENSE- RELATED TO LOSS ALAMEDA
IS. WAS THERE AN EVALUATION DONE
OF THE TRACK- WHAT CAN YOU TELL
ME IS THERE ANY. DO YOU WHAT DO
YOU BELIEVE WAS THE CAUSE OF THE
FINALITY SAID THAT TRACK WAS OR
ANALYSIS DONE AND IMPROVEMENTS
MADE TO THE TRUCK CAN YOU TELL
US ANYTHING ABOUT THAT IF YOU
REMEMBER. SOLD OF MOST RECENTLY
WITH THESE QUIET AND WE ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE SCIENCE LAST YEAR.
AGAIN FUTURE B. HAS HAS BEEN IN
DAILY CONTACT WITH LOS ALAMOS-
AND IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATE BUT
THEY HAVE THE TRACK ITSELF IS
IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATE SAFETY
ENHANCEMENTS AND CONSULTED
EXPERTS AND REYES- BOTH IN THE
RACING SURFACES- THEY'VE NOW
ASKED THEM VETERINARY RESEARCH
THEY'VE ASKED UC DAVIS TO GET
INVOLVED STUDYING- INTERESTING
THINGS LIKE THE LONG BAR
FRACTURES. IN QUARTER HORSES-
THAT'S COMING OFF OF- THE WAY IN
WHICH QUARTER HORSES RACE- IN
FULL- WITH A- TOWBAR- BATTER
THAT TECHNICALLY IS A LITTLE
OVER MY SKIS- BUT ALL I KNOW
THAT- THE BEST EXPERTS IN. THE
TRACK SURFACE WHEN ASKED TO LOOK
AT THIS LOOK AT IT IMMEDIATELY-
AND THEY'VE LOOKED AT ALL LAST
YEAR AND- THERE WAS A SPIKE
AGAIN AND WE DON'T KNOW WHY I
THINK IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
ACTUAL- OF THE LARGE BONE. BONES
THAT HAVE BEEN- IN THE HORSES
THEMSELVES FROM. EITHER
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS OR AND SO
WE'RE GETTING TO THE BTTOM OF
IT. FUTURE B. IS ON IT EVERY DAY
LOS AMIGOS CURRENTLY AND SO
AGAIN. IF WE DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE. THEY'VE GOT THIS
FALL WHETHER IT'S THE TRACK
SERVICE WE DON'T THINK IT'S THE
TRACK SURFACE. BUT IF IT IS- OR
WHAT OTHER REASONS THERE ARE WE
WILL. CALL AN EMERGENCY MEETING
ARE CHARMING TALKED ABOUT A WEEK
AGO WE WERE IN A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO ON WORK OR ALL OVER THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU HI. KNOW A LOT
GOES INTO IT AND I KNOW THE
EVALUATION OF THE TRACKS AND
THEN I KNOW WHAT THE PROTOCOL IS
ON THE TRACK. ON RACE DAY AND-
OBVIOUS YEAH. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GETTING MORE. TOOLS I JUST HOPE
WE CONTINUE TO PUSH OURSELVES TO
DO BETTER AND BETTER AND TO
FIGURE IT OUT BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT IT IS A SCIENCE- IN TERMS
OF HOW THOSE TRACKS OR LOOKED AT
BUT I. YOU KNOW YOU HAVE WE
ALWAYS ARE GOING TO ASK WHEN WE
SEE THIS BIKE AND WE ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE WAITING FOR ANSWERS
FROM THE- THE BOARD AND YOUR
EXPERTS THAT TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS. I WILL FOLLOW UP ON A
QUESTION- THAT. SENATOR GROWTH-
ASK ASK. AND TALKED ABOUT
RELATED TO- BELFORD AND THE
SUSPENSION- I WANTED HOW DO YOU
BALANCE THE RIGHT OF DUE PROCESS
AND MONITORING OF TRAINERS WITH
THE KNOWN HISTORY OF VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE I READ IN SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A KNOWN HISTORY OF
PROBLEMS THERE. AND ALONG THOSE
LINES THEN WHAT IS THE PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT THESE HORSES ARE
CARED FOR PROPERLY AT HAND I
KNOW AND HOW DOES THAT IMPACT
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE
SOMEONE OF THAT STATURE WITH
THAT MANY COURSES. AND THEY'RE
SUSPENDED IT HAS AN IMPACT ON
OBVIOUSLY- THE EMPLOYEES INTO
THE TRAINERS BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT BUT HOW ARE
THOSE FORCES THEN. HOW DO YOU
BALANCE THAT. AT THE MONITORING
OF THE TRAINERS AS WELL AS AS
DUE PROCESS. IN A CASE LIKE THIS
IS MY THIS IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT. MISTER BAFFERT HAS ALREADY
. BEEN SECURING HE SECURED TWO
OTHER TWO TRAINERS TWO DIFFERENT
TRAINERS THAT WILL TAKE OVER HIS
ENTIRE STATE- YEAH SANTA ANITA.
I WHICH IS PRIMARY BASE OF
OPERATIONS- AND SOLD OF I
FIGURES YOU KNOW HE'S HE HE HAS
TO SHUT DOWN- AND SO I'M SURE
THAT THE OTHER TRAINERS WILL TRY
AND- GET A HIGHER HIS SOME OF
HIS PEOPLE THERE THE- ACT
HANDLERS. OR SEIZE THE
BACKSTRETCH WORKERS- IF NOT
THEY'LL GET WORK SOMEWHERE ELSE
YOU'RE ALWAYS NEEDED THERE'S
BEEN A SHORTAGE. OF BACKSTRETCH
WORKERS. WE THINK BECAUSE A
COVERT SUCH SUCKS BUT- YOU KNOW
. YOU MAY OR MAY NOT TELL THE
CAT HORSE RACING HAS THE REST
RULE- WITH BEN WITH ALL STATE'S
RACING AND WITH OTHER
COMMISSIONS RACING COMMISSIONS
AND SO WE WILL LIVE BY WHATEVER
ELSE IS THE SUSPENSION OF NINETY
DAYS OF THE KENTUCKY HORSE
RACING COMMISSION AS- AS- GIVEN
TO. OF THE STRAFFORD WE ALSO
WILL LIVE BY THAT AND UP WITH
THIS RECIPROCITY RULES. I DON'T.
KNOW IF I ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
LIKE A PART OF YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU- I ONLY HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
HAS TO DO WITH ANOTHER
SUSPENSION WHICH IS THE EC ONE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AND I'LL BE
QUITE HONEST I DIDN'T KNOW OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD AND THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD. I WONDER I KNOW
YOU'RE TWO VERY SEPARATE BOARDS
BUT OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
SUSPENSION OF- THE DIRECTOR OF
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR- AND THEN
OF COURSE THE HORSE RACING BOARD
HAS EXPRESSED GREAT CONFIDENCE
IN IN. THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR THE
EQUINOX MEDICAL DIRECTOR. OUT
WHAT IS THIS INTERACTION-
BETWEEN THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD AND THEN THE IMPACT IT HAS
ON THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD. AND WHAT ROLE DO YOU HAVE
IN SELECTING OR APPROVING THE
EXONE MEDICAL DIRECTOR I'M JUST
CURIOUS. WELL FIRST OF ALL I AM
NOT AN EXPERT IN VETERINARY
MEDICINE. SO I CANNOT SPEAK TO
THE FULL COMPLEXITY OF THESE
ISSUES- BROUGHT ON BY THE
VETERINARY- BOARD ST BERNARD
BOARD AND- SEIZURE VIA OUR
HOWEVER I FULLY SUPPORT DR
GLORIA- DUTIES PROFESSIONAL
EXCELLENCE AND EXPERTISE. IS
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT. TO
EQUINE HEALTH AND SAFETY- BEYOND
THAT THE BATTER IS RIGHT NOW
BEING DECIDED BY THE COURTS.
AND- I DON'T- PART OF IT IS A
POTENTIAL PENDING LITIGATION SO
THE BOARD WERE WERE- I CANNOT
SAY FURTHER- YOU KNOW- WHAT WILL
BE HANDED DOWN HERE BUT- I'VE I
FEEL THAT IT'S- THERE'S
DEFINITELY A DISCONNECT- I'M I'M
SORRY THAT THEY HAD TO SUSPEND
DOCTOR BLAIR. WITHOUT ALLOWING
HIM DUE PROCESS- AND WE DO STAND
BEHIND- WE I DO. STAND BEHIND DR
GLORIA OF THE BORDER THIS VOTE
AND PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED THEIR
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND CONFIDENCE
IN DR YEAH AS THE EQUINE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR. IN DO OUR RESPECTIVE
HIM AS ONE OF THE MOST TO FEED
VETERINARIANS IN THE COUNTRY-
AND FLOW IN OUR CREATION FOR HIS
LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT TO. THE
ONE OR. AND REALLY ANSWERED OUR
ACTIONS I'M SORRY NOW I'M
KIDDING I WOULD JUST SAY TO YOU
AND YOU KNOW AND ALL THE YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE- DOING
CONFIRMATIONS WE MAKE
APPOINTMENTS TO ALL OF THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION BOARDS AS
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
CLEARLY THE GOVERNOR MAKES
APPOINTMENTS TO THOSE BOARDS AND
ADD TO BE QUITE HONEST I NEVER
ACTUALLY. HAVE HAD AN EXAMPLE OF
THE INTERACTION BETWEEN AN
ACTION TAKEN BY. ABOARD THE
VETERINARY- BOARD. AND THE
IMPACT THAT THEN I SEE IT HAS ON
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD SO THIS IS A FIRST FOR ME
TO SEE THIS PLAY OUT OBVIOUSLY
IT MAY BE FOR YOU AS WELL BUT
FOR US WHEN WE ARE. BONTA MADE
THE VISUALS AND THE HORSE RACING
HAS STEP. HISTORY OF BEING ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT SAFETY ON TRACKS
AND HORSE DEATHS AND THEN WE SEE
THE INTERSECTION OF THE
VETERINARY BOARD AND SOME
QUESTION LIKE YOU I DON'T THINK
ANY OF US UP HERE OR IN A
POSITION TO- VALUE WAIT AND
ACTION BY THE VETERINARY BOARD
ANYMORE THAT WAS THEN WE ARE
ABOUT ASSESSING RACE TRACK
QUALITY AND- THE ISSUE. MIGHT BE
THERE BUT I WANT TO RAISE IT TO
YOU BECAUSE- WE ARE THE ONES
THAT WILL GET THE CALLS ABOUT-
HORSE DEATHS AND- WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO OVERSEE AND MONITOR
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT AT THE
TRACKS. OF WHICH I BELIEVE IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND LEGACY
AND OF COURSE I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD ART
RIGHTS FREQUENTLY- SO. A
DIFFERENT KIND OF INTEREST SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT IT TO YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW IF THE BOARD HAS
EXPRESSED GREAT SUPPORT OF
DOCTOR BLADE A AND- AND I HAVE
NO REASON. TO THINK THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A BETTER ASSESSMENT
OF HIS QUALITIES- THAN I DO. BUT
I JUST HAVE TO PUT IT THERE IS A
QUESTION AND SAY WE ARE GOING TO
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO MONITOR NOW
THIS INTERSECTION. HI AS THINGS
MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT THAT AS
WELL- I THINK WE WERE ALL VERY
STE. STE ABOUT THAT WOULD YOU
JUST EXPLAIN. I'M HOW VETERINARY
BOARD YOU KNOW. AND HOW THIS
HAPPENED WITH DOCTOR. I DO KNOW
THERE IS ON GOING HEARINGS- AND
SO- REGARDING THE ACT
ACCUSATIONS- REMAINS OF. SO WILL
WILL MONITOR THE START WERE VERY
MUCH INVOLVED. IN THE MEANTIME
THERE TOO YOU KNOW VERY
QUALIFIED. PROFESSIONAL. DOCTORS
FROM UC DAVIS ARE ARE THEY CAN
FOR SETTING AND- DOING GREAT
WORK IN IN DR PLACE PLACE WELL
IN A THANK YOU AND I HAPPEN TO
KNOW THAT UC DAVIS IS PROBABLY.
THE FOREMOST. SCHOOL AS IT
RELATES TO ASK ONE OF CARE-
ECCENTRICITY. IF YOU WOULD JUST
ON MY BEHALF I WILL NOT SPEAK
FOR MY COLLEAGUES BUT IF YOU
WILL CARRY BACK TO THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
THAT WE THAT I AT LEAST DID
EXPRESS THIS CONCERN ABOUT THE
JUXTAPOSITION. AND THE ROLE THAT
THE HORSE RACING BOARD TOK IN
EXPRESSING THEIR SUPPORT AND YET
HERE WE ARE STILL OUT HERE WITH
THE CONCERN ABOUT AN ACTION THE
VETERINARY BOARD TOOK I THINK I
JUST NEED TO SAY THAT FOR THE
RECORD. AND CERTAINLY MOVE ON
BECAUSE I DO THINK THE RECORD
REFLECTS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN PART
OF AN INCREDIBLE- CHANGE IN
TERMS OF. THE ACTIONS TAKEN AT
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD TO ENHANCE AND SUPPORT THE
HEALTH OF HORSES SO I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT IS REFLECTED ON THE
RECORD TOO BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL OF THAT BUT
IF YOU CARRY THAT MESSAGE BACK
TO THE BOARD. RELATED TO THIS
CONCERN THAT WE CANNOT KNOW MUCH
ABOUT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT IS
OBVIOUSLY AND AS YOU SAID- I
HEARING PROCESS AND THE COURTS
SO. I AND I WANT TO END ON ON
BEFORE WE GO TO THE PUBLIC. IN
MY COMMENTS JUST BY SAYING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS AND YOUR-
COMMITMENT TO THIS WORK AND
THANK YOU FOR THE POSITIVE
CHANGES THAT HAS. RESULTED IN A
BETTER OUTCOME- SO I THINK I
JUST OTHER. ABSOLUTELY OF WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND I'M GONNA START RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE
IF WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE. AND I DO NOT SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK.
WITH IN IN PERSON SO I'M GONNA
GO BACK TO OUR MODERATOR AND
ASKED IF- THEY WOULD TEE UP THE
CALLS IN SUPPORT OF THIS-
APPOINTEE FOR RE APPOINTMENT AND
CONFIRMATION. EIGHT AND ONLY IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IT'S ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND THERE'S
NOBODY QUEUEING UP AND SHARE.
MADAME MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL COME PATCHWORK WILL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU BECAUSE I
SEE NO ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PHYSICALLY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO MADAM MODERATOR
WANTED TO GO AHEAD AND T. OF
PEOPLE WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAKIN
OPPOSITION. TO THE APPOINTMENT.
YOU ARE OPPOSITION IT IS ONE
ZERO. OPPOSITION ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND THERE IS
SOMEBODY QUEUING UP HERE OKAY
JUST ONE MOMENT. AND ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S OPPOSITION OF ONE IN ZERO. WELL THREE ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
A- THEMSELVES- ONE HUNDRED BACK
IN THE QUEUE. ONE NINE ZERO ONE
TIME FOR YOU TO STAY IN THE
QUEUE. AND WE WILL GO. NUMBER.
OPPOSITION. ONE NINE ZERO. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY FIVE. AND I'M SURE THEY
DON'T THE ONE ZERO AGAIN AND
TOOK A MATIC YOU. THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE THANK YOU FOR OPPOSITION.
MADAME MODERATOR THANK YOU I
WILL- GIVE DIRECTION TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC OF HOW THEY CAN
ALSO MAKE US AWARE- WE WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THEY WOULD
GO ON TO OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS IF FOR SOME REASON
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IN THE
QUEUE ORDER OR TO FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THE- DIRECTIONS- WE WANT TO
ALLOW PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO DO
TESTIMONY SO IF. THEY WEREN'T
ABLE TO THEY CAN SUBMIT THEIR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO A RULES COMMITTEE
VISIT OUR WEBSITE- WE REALLY DO
THINK THESE COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT SO BETTER MODERATOR
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP
TODAY AND TO YOUR COUNTERPART
WHO WAS WITH US IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE HEARING. I KEEP UP YOUR HELP
A IF THAT COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION. I AM
HEARING US SENATOR CALM WATER
HAS MADE A MOTION TO- MOVE THIS
CONFEREE AN APPOINTMENT FORWARD
SO MATTER. YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I. BYE BYE. HI THE I. FIVE
ZERO MR ALFIERI IF I WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS IN YOUR ANSWERS
AND COMMENTS ON OUR QUESTIONS
TODAY AND WE CONGRATULATE YOU
AND YOU YOUR APPOINTMENT WILL
MOVE ON TO THE SENATE FOR FULL
CONFIRMATION SO AGAIN WE SEE.
FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATORS THANK YOU HAVE A
GREAT REST OF YOUR DAY. THANK
YOU SO- GO BACK WE HAVE- MATTERS
ON CALL SO LET ME JUST GO
COMPLETELY DOWN THE ROLE OF
MADAM SECRETARY AND ASK FOR YOU
TO OPEN THE ROLE ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
ITEM ONE A. SUSAN MORRIS AS
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF AGING. THAT IS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU ARE WE WILL MOVE TO
ITEM ONE B. NICOLE ELLIOTT AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL OPEN THE ROLE.
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE WILL JUST- ON ITEM-
I THINK WE TOOK BILL REFERRALS
WE TOOK ITEM TO REFERENCE OF
BILLS AND ITEM FOR FLOORING
KNOWLEDGE MINTS TOGETHER. OPEN
THE ROLE. I THANK YOU. THAT
LEAVES US WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE
THE RULE WAIVER- MADAM SECRETARY
OPEN THE ROLE ROTHE RO NO THREE
TWO TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU AND
WITH THAT ARM AGAIN LET ME- SAY
THAT TODAY'S PORTION OUR PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA IS
CONCLUDED AND I WANT TO THANK
AGAIN ALL THE VISUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY WAS PARTICULARLY. POLICY
ARE SOME MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE TO COMMENT
BUT IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO BUT
A DAY AGAIN. MAKE YOUR- RUSSIANS
IN WRITING TO THE RULES OR VISIT
OUR FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY IMPORTANT TO US AND WE
WANT TO BE SURE AND INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR COOPERATION
TODAY YOUR PATIENTS ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES ONE NOW MOVES
TO THE EXECUTIVE SESSION.